[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
émission spéciale qui marque la fin du
voyage du pape françois au canada
l'avion du souverain pontife
parti de québec ce midi a atterri à
évaluer qu'ils voient les images que
vous voyez sont en direct de cette
capitale la capitale du territoire du
nunavut
il va donc à la rencontre d'autres
survivants des pensionnats cela issu du
peuple inouk ce qu'on appelle les inuits
pour l'occasion nous reviendrons sur ce
passé douloureux et ses conséquences
encore aujourd'hui pour les inuits et
nous ferons le bilan du voyage
pénitentielle du pape au canada et qui
de mieux pour faire le bilan que celui
qui a tout suivi depuis le début et même
avant je dirais notre spécialiste en
affaires religieuses alain crevier
bonjour merci d'être avec nous de québec
cette fois oui ça va merci et la
psychiatre marié ève coton qui
pratiquent régulièrement au centre de
santé de l'ungava à coups de joie dans
le nunavik ça c'est la partie québécoise
du territoire innu qui sont peu dire
bonjour madame coton merci d'être de
retour parmi nous vous étiez là le lundi
le jour où on attendait ses excuses du
pape à edmonton
maintenant je vous propose d'aller sur
place à iqaluit où le pape donc on a vu
arriver mathieu bouyer vous êtes sur
place
alors dites nous dit tout ce qui se
passe
vous l'avez dit d'entrée de jeu le pape
vient tout juste d'arriver à égalité de
la capitale du nunavut il est entre
autres accueilli par le premier ministre
du nunavut le ministre fédéral des
affaires du nord une courte cérémonie
d'accueil pour le pape ou d'une voûte
assez rapidement il va se rendre où on
se trouve ici présentement à l'école
primaire la cass soc et ici à l'école
primaire ça va se passer en deux temps
geneviève y aura d'abord une rencontre
privée comme lieu à québec plus tôt
aujourd'hui avec des survivants des
pensionnats le pape voulait prendre du
temps pour s'adresser à eux les écouter
aussi surtout ça faisait partie
évidemment des demandes qu'il y avait
ici alors ce qu'on a su que le pape
allait se rendre à iqaluit ensuite
deuxième partie il y aura un événement
public et c'est pour ça que vous voyez
autant de gens autour de moi vieux
l'école là c'est nouveau être le pape
mais depuis environ trentaine de minutes
l'on veut vraiment de plus en plus de
gens qui arrivent ici avec alibi pour
apercevoir écouter le pas parce que bien
sûr le peuple va s'adresser aux gens un
seuil qu'elle évite aux survivants aux
inuits visite pas toujours facile et de
la psychologie qui est offerte également
ici sur le terrain parce qu'on le sait
cette visite ces paroles du pape
peut-être ses excuses qui devait répéter
d'ailleurs tantôt ça ravive des douleurs
et qui sont évidemment encore très
présente très vivre il ya deux lettres
écologique à faire sur place
une visite pas évident tant parce que
partout où il est passé le pape sas a
amené justement des souvenirs douloureux
c'est encore le cas ici à égaliser il ya
quelques minutes après je me suis
entretenu avec une bénévole ici qui est
à pied d'oeuvre avec d'autres pour
préparer l'accueil du pape faciliter un
peu les choses sur le terrain elle même
n'est pas une limite mais ses enfants le
sont elle nous raconte un peu l'état
d'esprit dans lequel il qualifie était
plongé depuis quelques jours en
attendant l'arrivée du pape nous raconte
aussi l'importance et les attentes
reliés à cette visite peut être brève à
peine trois heures du pape ici mais
quand même néanmoins très importante
pour les inuits ont pu coûter la rote
hampton à qui j'ai parlé il ya quelques
minutes
c'est une semaine particulièrement
l'autre particulière
émotionnelle
pour nous tous je peux parler au nom des
minutes c'est une visite qui très
entendu des paroles qui sont très
attendus surtout des survivants qui
attendent toute une vie
malheureusement le grand père
de maicon c'est la peau
n'ai plus envie n'occuperait y aurait
d'après la famille de michael aurait
bénéficié
d'un temps ces paroles là c'est un
moment aussi rassemblant
pour nous et nous n'avons muse et pour
les normes us cette semaine la porte à
beaucoup réfléchir
avec nous
rien d'humilité et
grinçant
de compassion pour les peuples commis
qui
qui ont vie vécue tout autre chose
et on voit derrière vous on vous l'avait
montré cette scène où le spectacle aussi
on veut va se dérouler dans des
prestations musicales des danses
traditionnelles je pense
que ce serait une visite qui est musique
culturel à saveur culturelle de la
programmation cobas derrière mon
l'entente parce que les inuits ne
veulent montrer au peuple aux yeux du
monde qui sont tournés vers la visite
papale que la culture est nu et aide
encore forte qu'elle a survécu aux
tentatives d'assimilation entre autres
perpétrés par l'église catholique à la
c'est très important pour les
organisateurs ici sur place de montrer
de faire entendre la culture autochtone
alors on aura droit à du tambour à des
chants de gorge de la danse bref une
démonstration culturel qui était fort
importante pour les survivants les
organisateurs on peut d'ailleurs tout de
suite écoutez là dessus un des
survivants et des artistes qu'on pourra
entendre dans quelques minutes
we have you lie
alors le programme publié avant le
programme ici à l'école va commencer
dans quelques minutes geneviève on le
dit d'entrée de jeu le pape est ici à
peine trois heures mais quand même ça ça
demeure restaurée qui te visite papale
encore plus au nunavut à 8 elle est
peut-être brève la visite ici mais on
nous dit parmi les survivants et leurs
proches qu'elle était néanmoins fort
important cette vision mais oui dans les
images que nous voyons en direct
monsieur vous êtes peut-être pas pu les
voir mais envoyait entre autres
survivants monsieur tout dessus qui en
serrant la main du pape s'est mise à
pleurer que vous nous avez fait entendre
7 autres survivants qui évidemment
attend beaucoup espèrent beaucoup de ce
passage du pape à ica 8 merci beaucoup
monsieur boyer merci
alors avant de pousser avec le plateau
je suis de dire que michèle audette la
sénatrice s'est jointe à nous bonjour
coup et michel merci d'être avec nous
alors allez on va faire une espèce de
bilan on va commencer à faire un petit
peu un bilan
le pape en venant ici a fait un grand
pas parce qu'il a rencontré des
survivants chez eux comme ils veulent
faire tout à l'heure dans quelques
instants eyeka 8 oui c'est vrai et je
fais juste remarquer que je voyais ça
dans les images en direct
le pape debout pour accueillir du monde
c'est de distribuer des chapelets ben
parce qu on est tellement habitué
maintenant on est même habitué de voir
le premier ministre qui se penche pour
lui parler parce que plutôt apaisée des
difficultés du genou mais aussi on voit
qu'il ya de la douleur et le ce que je
vois comme image c'est quelqu'un que la
détresse de renaître d'ailleurs je vais
pas plus tard que ce matin et même chose
hier le message qu'il envoyait au
premier peuple c'était vraiment comme
s'il faisait partie de la famille est
alors je me semble parmi vous je me sens
avec vous aussi j'ai pas là mais si je
comptais ou discours de dimanche en fait
de surtout de lundi au cimetière après
ça au lac sainte anne et tout ça le
discours a changé et je vous disais j'ai
le sentiment que j'avais c'est qu'on
allait partir de la constatation d'un
drame d'une tragédie c'est ce que je
pense qu'on a vu avec les images du pape
dans une matière en alberta edmonton des
là on voit qu'ils se dirigent avec des
idées qui s'approche plus de l'espoir
oui on peut dire qu'on a franchi le cap
et la réconciliation et de guérison puis
tout le reste mais c'était prévisible
qu'il ferait quelque chose comme ça
alors j'ai hâte de voir ce qui va ce qui
va faire comme discours tantôt mais je
pense qu'il est il semble être un homme
et c'est ce qui nous a dit m c'est un
homme qui a été transformée par les
rencontres et on a tous compris que les
rencontres cpo celle de cette semaine
c'est celle qui tue depuis des mois ce
sont les échanges qu'il y ait eu depuis
des mois des gens qui sont allés cogner
à sa porte pour lui d écouter nous en
grand mare la ja par qui a agressé des
enfants qui a agressé des gens pouvaient
nous aider à le retracer faire en sorte
que ça va jusqu'à l'aude alors je pense
qu'on a affaire à un homme qui a été
touché mais je pense que c'est pas le
nom je suis convaincu de ce que je vous
dis là c'est pas le nombre de deux
personnes qui n'étaient pas sur les
plaines hier parce qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de monde c'est pas ça qu'ils
soient à vous retenir ses passages que
sap avoir retenu il va reconnaître
quelque chose qui est plus fondamental
il l'a voulu autre cas michel on peut
dire une chose séjour du pape au canada
c'est que son discours a tout de même
progressé
depuis depuis son arrivée dimanche
jusqu'à hier sur les plaines et
peut-être même encore aujourd'hui on va
l'entendre tout à l'heure il va
s'adresser à ceux longuement à la
population de 10 cas 8 mai il a
progressé comme un peu un politicien et
s'est adapté aussi parce que les gens
réagissaient on avait toutes sortes de
réactions à ces premiers secours et
finalement il a rajouté des choses qu'il
ne disait pas au début
et c'est ça en effet il a rajouté des
choses est ce que c'était calculer
est-ce que c'était prévu ou un mélange
de tout tout simplement parce que c'est
une personne qui entend ou moi j'ai
jamais vu un peuple qui a un twitter je
comprends que ces produits qu'il fait le
maire est quand même assez à jour donc
les gens devaient lui dire voici le
mécontentement de bien des gens à
travers le canada et de l'entendre
hier soir ça
ça oui ça va me faire du bien mais ça va
confirmer que ce qu'on a partagé pendant
des décennies est réellement arrivé à
nuancer et que maintenant une grande
église il représente la grande église
même si on parle de communauté à
quelques endroits paix les mots ont été
importants et maintenant le temps de
qualité avec les inuit bref au cidre est
précieux parce que le fait de dire des
mots comme abus sexuels par exemple
c'est une validation c'est une
reconnaissance que ça bel et bien été
vécu
exactement geneviève c'est comme alors
c'est mon parallèle très personnel je
suis devant un jury c'est oui ou non on
voit de la tâche et passe à des preuves
à l'effet est institué donc une réponse
qui va être très bonnes ou très mauvaise
alors là il manquait un élément
important qui était parmi les grands
traumatismes auxquels on a fait face
pendant trop longtemps mais il en
rajoute et où il a ajouté celui qui
c'est important pour toutes ces victimes
là alors ça pour moi je vous dirais
est-ce que c'est du courage
est ce que c'est parce que il veut que
ses collègues
l'entente de sa bouche avant de partir
peut-être tous ensemble mais au moins
c'est dit ouais madame coton justement
du point de vue puisque le g que pour la
psychiatre que vous êtes c'est mme odile
de la part du chef de l'église c'est
très important dans la reconnaissance de
la souffrance de ces gens qui ont subi
les pensionnaires absolument parce que
les abus sexuels ont été au coeur des
traumatismes dans les pensions étaient
extrêmement fréquents et ça faisait
partie de mes critiques quand je fais me
le dit à l'émission où ça se passe à
edmonton à ce moment là il n'avait pas
prononcé à ce moment là il y avait parlé
d' abus verbal et physique mais c'était
une grosse mission pour moi que ce soit
pas nommé les abus sexuels et le fait de
valider le fait de reconnaître parce que
d'eux qu'ils soient reconnus comme ça de
la part de l'église quand les gens sont
traumatisés quand ils ont souffert c'est
une espèce de c'est comme ça venait
légitimer un peu leur souffrance validé
qui se sont pas sentis six blessés pour
rien alors je pense que ça peut avoir
des impacts positifs parce que michel et
marie-eve ces traumatismes des
pensionnats ont été en semi cacher pour
ne pas dire nier par l'église mais par
les victimes elles mêmes pendant des
années des décennies les parents ne
disait pas à leurs enfants qu'ils
étaient passés par les pensionnats n'est
ce pas michel même et c'est vrai ce que
vous dites même s'il ya eu trois
commission denquête qui vont traverser
l'histoire ici au canada c'est de la
commission royale sur les peuples
autochtones et ensuite la commission de
vérité et réconciliation est bien sûr
celle sur les femmes et filles
autochtones assassiné disparu j'ai été
témoin de voir trois quatre générations
devant nous les commissaires de pakua
shipi une famille de pakua shipi et la
violence coloniale qu'il est connecté ou
qui les liait dans ces générations là on
parle d'une famille de quatre
générations étaient les effets des
pensionnats les politiques qui émanait
de là alors j'ai fait c'est partout et
c'était présente le nous deux et
troisième générations en prend le chemin
qui a été difficile mais faut pas
oublier ce qui s'est passé là même quand
on vous qui vous vous rendez dans le
fond dans mon avis que quoi aux deux
mois deux semaines ou deux mois depuis
depuis plus de 20 ans êtes-vous soignés
essentiellement les communautés innues
est qu'elles soient sur place ou navic
ou dc en télétravail
diriez vous que leurs attentes face à
cette venue du pape qui étant chez eux
là aujourd'hui sont différentes escales
des particularités chez les inuits qui
sont différentes qu'ont vécu les autres
premiers peuples je dirais que la
colonisation s'est fait un petit peu
plus tard pour les inuits ils sont
géographiquement les plus éloignés des
centres au sud où se trouvent beaucoup
le peuple leblanc donc on parle la
sédentarisation des inuits s'est
complétée dans les années 60 donc au
niveau historique c'est très récent donc
les changements de mode de vie et les
impacts du choc de mode de vie se
rencontrent un petit peu plus
fréquemment chez les inuit dirais que
c'est une des différences et je suis
certaine que les inuits aussi sont
probablement apprécié le fait que le
pape se rendent sur leur territoire
justement parce que s'éloigner il est si
éloignée donc parfois cio je pense qu'il
sauve comme pub d'être moins connus ou
d'être moins peut-être représenter parce
qu'ils sont très éloignées donc on on
les fréquente moins on les croise - où
ils sont moins souvent l'espace public
donc je pense que c'est une belle
reconnaissance ur e66 pour eu cet
événement le était attendu effectivement
on le sait c'est très loin se rendre là
et ça coûte très cher se rendre là où en
sortie ou recevoir danois est sûre enfin
une vie compliquée je vais joindre
encore sur place ma collègue marie laure
josselin qui est journaliste un espace
autochtone le site radio canadienne
marie laure vous êtes à iqaluit tu
depuis quelques jours vous à vais
rencontrer des survivants inuits je
pense que vous m'entendez par
marie-laure alors peut-être qu'on va on
va revenir avoue un peu plus tard quand
la communication sera rétablie mais pour
revenir à ce qu'elle nous entend
maintenant larry l'homme entendez-vous a
alors bonjour marie lowy je vous entends
très bien combien ces stages à l'elysée
je disais que vous aviez rencontré des
survivants et nuit qu attendent beaucoup
de cette rencontre avec le pape
effectivement on a entendu justement
juste avant vos invités qui parlait de
d'oralité d'importance de mettre les
mots il ya des gens qui attendent de
toute leur vie en fait depuis depuis
qu'ils sont petits qu'ils attendent ce
pardon c'est quand même une tradition de
l'oralité ici et dans les dents les
peuples autochtones donc ils ont
l'impression que quand le pape va
pouvoir prononcer ces mots ce sont les
mots qui vont rester dans l'histoire
orale qui est très importante c'est leur
histoire qu'il réécrive ils me disent
que pour eux sur leur terre ça une
signification différente bien sûr il ya
eu les excuses à rome il ya eu edmonton
y ait du québec mais pour eux qu'ils
viennent et qui viennent les écouter
d'autant plus que vous voyez il n'y a
pas énormément de monde les survivantes
son arrivée par un bus et ils sont à
l'intérieur derrière moi donc c'est très
intime comme rencontre ils vont pouvoir
prendre quelque temps même si c'est
chronométrés je vous dirais vraiment à
la minute près mais vont pouvoir prendre
un peu de temps et pouvoir dire ce qui
s'est passé comment ils ont été
déracinés et comme déjà cette rencontre
risque d'être significatif pour eux pour
avancer pour se pardonner à eux mêmes de
s'être tue parfois de ne pas d'avoir
fait du mal aussi à leurs familles à
cause du pensionnat à cause du silence
et puis moi ce que j'ai revu aussi ces
derniers jours ce sont des combats des
compagnons d'enfance qui se retrouve
certains se sont pas vus depuis 93 en
tout cas une grosse réunion comme ça et
donc ce sont des compagnons d'enfance
qui ont été retirés tous petits des
compagnons de lutte des compagnons
silence des compagnons de blessure et là
des compagnons de cette histoire oui
parce qu'ils sont venus c'est un vaste
territoire par densément peuplées c'est
plutôt le contraire ils sont venus de
très loin et pour pouvoir rencontrer le
par
effectivement il ya des gens qui sont
venus de tchétchénie l'aide de rankin
inlet donc d'un peu partout pas que du
nunavut qui a aussi des survivants du
nunavik à peu près huit survivants du
nunavik donc le nord du québec qui
viennent de quatre communautés il ya
aussi d'autres quatre parties les quatre
partis on va dire inuit du canada qui
sont venus les dignitaires certains
dignitaires ont décidé de ne pas venir
de la partie ouest parce qu'ils ont dit
nous on veut des actions concrètes mais
vous avez quand même des gens qui sont
venus de partout évidemment tout le
monde n'est pas là parce que les
conditions de santé certains ne
permettent pas de venir y en a qui ne
veulent pas venir aussi il faut quand
même le rappeler que ce n'est pas un
événement qui rallie tout le monde et
que ça reste encore divisée comme on l'a
entendu depuis plusieurs jours sur nos
zones mais ici aussi c'est le cas donc
ils sont faits ce ces kilomètres là
parce que je le répète pour eux c'est
important d'entendre le pape vous avez
tout à l'heure mathieu mon collègue a
passé une entrevue de pita ironique avec
qui j'ai parlé hier puis en 2009 il est
allé à à rome avec phil fontaine le
délégué la fin pour avec la délégation
de l'assemblée premières nations il
espérait rencontrer le pape il l'a vu
d'assez proche me disait-il aussi
proches qu'il me voyait quand on se
parlait assis derrière et il me dit mais
par contre j'ai pas pu lui parler et
puis il n'a pas fait d'excusés donc vous
voyez c'est vraiment il ya cette attente
l'a vraiment très très clair pour eux et
puis évidemment même si le pape a parlé
hier à nommer les abus sexuels ici ils
veulent l'entendre dire on sait très
bien que je vous le rappelle en tout cas
que ou déjà à rome au vatican le leader
in ou que nhat hanh aubade avait demandé
que le pape interfère dans le cas yoann
s rivoire ce prêtre accusé de pédophilie
nalité dans les années 70 à fuir en
france et qui est toujours finalement la
justice n'a pas encore réussi à le
rattraper donc puis tahir nick me disais
moi je veux lui parler spécifiquement ça
c'est pas passé pendant les pensionnats
évidemment on parle beaucoup des
pensionnats il faut pas oublier ce qui
s'est passé après les pensionnats mais
ici justement les survivants veulent le
rappeler au pape
merci beaucoup marie laure jassem merci
pour votre témoignage faire en apprécie
votre collaboration
au revoir oui nous entende un jour vous
voyez réagir messieurs nos dettes à ce
que vient de dire marie laure jocelyn
que c'est pas juste pendant les
personnels mais depuis les pensionnats
ou si c'est passé énormément de choses
et pas du tout pour le mieux pour ces
populations des premiers peuples
en effet puis c'est c'est chaud se
rappeler que les écoles de jour lorsque
les pensionnaires vont fermer à travers
le canada dans les années 60-70 on va
fermer les pensionnats alors que nous à
partir de 1950 jusqu'en 1993 au québec
on ouvre les pensionnats donc il ya
encore trois générations très vivante
encore vivante et qui ont une mémoire de
ce qui s'est passé alors ces frais
encore way et puis pour les inuits de la
voir de façon intime je ne savais pas
quoi salir semblait alors les images que
vous nous partager sont importantes mais
je leur souhaite je leur souhaite de
prendre le temps et de pouvoir avoir ce
moment juste pour eux pour nous je sais
pas si vous avez eu l'occasion vous
michel gaudette parce que vous êtes vous
vous êtes déplacé en alberta entre
autres avez vous pu parler vous même au
pape non en suisse tu as essayé de me
faire silencieuse d'ailleurs de
l'entendre la petite fille qui arrive de
deux sticks gauche mais non j'ai essayé
de rester le plus en retrait parce que
c'était aux gens de ce territoire là où
de ce grand territoire lot de pouvoir
avoir quelques secondes sinon quelques
minutes avec le pape auriez vous aimé
mes parler
aujourd'hui oui mais pas en début de
semaine et pourquoi plus aujourd'hui
qu'en début de semaine
parce que il dit les choses qui étaient
importantes pour beaucoup de gens que
j'aime pis pour mes filles pour mes fils
pour moi pour ma grand mère c'est les
gens que j'aime beaucoup i love fait le
cercle des violences coloniales
alors là j'ai arrêté mais vierge quand
je répit dans mes bras quelques secondes
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est plutôt
sympathique en tout cas ce vieillard
parce qu'il faut le dire 85 ans pas en
forme faire un tel voyage faire ce reste
quand même cette main tendue finalement
vers les peuples autochtones et bien je
vous propose maintenant d'entendre une
jeune latika mec qui n'a pas été dans un
pensionnat mais qui le subit quand même
elle s'appelle shoiry nkuku elle a écrit
co réalisé en fait documentaire qui
s'appelle un mur invisible
bonjour madame coucou bon jouer
alors je pense que vous n'avez que 22
ans je pense qu'on peut dire que vous
avez enfin je me demande en fait à ce
que vous avez suivi la visite de pape du
pas parce que vous avez entendu ces
paroles ses demandes de pardon
j'ai pas suivi de près la visite du pape
je les subis à travers les réseaux
sociaux qu'est ce qu'on voyait à travers
les interviews qu on voyait que les
pages actualités postées sur la page
facebook qu'ils font mais j'ai poursuivi
qu'est ce qui se passait parce que c'est
pas quelque chose qui m'a interpellé au
niveau personnel de support des mots que
j'attendais avec impatience
personnes vous avez même je crois refusé
d'être baptisé parce que vous avez
rejeté finalement cette religion
catholique à cause de ce que vos quatre
grands parents paternels et maternels
ont subi dans les pensionnats n'est ce
pas oui c'est seulement comme un espace
tout en grandissant les parents m'ont
toujours dans les choix au niveau de la
réligion m'ont dit c'est ton choix toi
si tu veux te faire baptiser ou non si
tu le désires de pas faire baptiser
c'est correct si tu décides de faire
baptiser ses collègues et on va faire
les démarches qui vont avec mais moi
c'est pas quelque chose qui et que je
voulais faire juste à avoir l'histoire
des pensionnats justement pas vos plus
grands parents pas aussi
j'avais zappé questionnement en
grandissant parce que tu m'as j'ai
toujours mes grands parents surtout les
grands parents
comment se croyant ou incroyant oui et
moi je comprenais pas malgré tout ce
pour quoi pourquoi sont autant que
voyons pourquoi centrale tout en
pratiquant malgré tout ce qui s'est
passé tout ce que tout ce que ça nous a
apporté de mal encore que j'ai posé la
question à ma grand-mère la supporter
pourquoi tu penses que marine était
autant pour région période je pense que
c'est l'effet qu'on est tellement ancrée
dans l'ours et vous que c'était mal et
d'autochtones qu'est ce que c'était
mauvais pis qu'il y avait une solution
de s'en sortir c'était en pratiquant en
pliant pour une meilleure vie après la
mort en tout cas on peut dire que dans
votre cas l'impact des pensionnats ne
s'est pas arrêtée avec vos grands
parents votre mère ou si on a souffert
oui c'est ce mois d'immigrés
pareillement possible par les
pensionnats appelé le
matériel
ma grand mère a eu un avc suite à sa
sortie de temps après elle avait déjà
deux trois enfants paquette enfants
citation l'avc de tes enfants ont été
pris donc arretez miens famille
d'accueil or des communautés de la com
de tommy john en fait qu'ils ont fini à
la cicc latu débarqueront à 90 milliards
d'euros de droits ne s'est pas coté
ok bien toute la déconnexion des vous de
la culture qui sait pas si t'es sûr que
ma grand mère a une certaine difficulté
de voir si certaines traditions surtout
sur les aspects de la culture qui venait
à cause d elle même à laver pour axer
ses informations à cause ses idéaux
passionnant ouais d'enfants c'est un
autre aspect aussi de l'acculturation
des autochtones la protection fiance
d'ailleurs la commission vérité
réconciliation avait tout un chapitre
sur la question ça il faut que ça change
aussi à ce niveau là faut que les
autochtones eux mêmes prennent en charge
les enfants que la dpj autrement
prendrait prendrait en charge maintenant
vous avez réalisé documentaire le mur
invisible pour parler de ce mur qui quoi
qui entoure encore les autochtones qui
les isole encore
et je pense que le principe d'une révisé
de l'eau soit au regard du documentaire
c'est qu'on comprend que ces différents
chacune pour moi dans mon cockpit avait
commencé le mur invisible c'est un lieu
qui était construit autour de moi même
avant ma naissance qui me donnait pas
accès au même niveau à la même qualité
de vie que les nomades d'apple un prix
puis justement je parlais d'été
des conséquences des pensionnats que moi
j'ai vécu à travers
on parle ici de certains problèmes de
consommation de membres de ma famille on
parle de deux là ont des tonnes à la
limite parce qu'on voit tout le temps en
nous présente tout le temps les
stéréotypes qu'on vous dit tout le temps
mais vous vous êtes comme ça vous êtes
comme ça vous êtes comme ça car la
fermeture du but comme s'est dissocié un
peu plus tassé de fitte est dans une
poule
où tu des personnes que tu vaux aux
alentours de toi mais c'est jamais que
tu veux pouvoir être comme lui parce que
t'es pas connu des gens partent en fac
c'est tout un processus de décoloniser
justement toutes ses pensées là pour
écrire de qui je suis aujourd'hui ce sol
était très dur ça a été beaucoup de
larmes versées beaucoup c'est seulement
par rapport à moi-même beaucoup de haine
envers moi-même en fait éventuellement
si tu j'en suis aujourd'hui c'est plus
de compassion envers moi même puis
comprend que oui c'est dommage qu'ils
étaient passés par l'eau mais aussi une
histoire de pourquoi aujourd'hui talent
il était chez et comment l'été j'étais
donc c'est plus lent ce style de combat
est
fini
alors vous dites que vous allez
justement vous avez dépassé cet état de
honte de vous même en réalisant ce
documentaire entre autres j'imagine
est-ce que vous ayez ben oui c'est sûr
que c'est qu'à travers le documentaire
mais j'étais sale éditions ki oon
aquitain collège fait par et pour les
autochtones où j'ai vraiment pu prendre
un peu de recul pour commencer pour
vraiment qu'on grimpe tiechui en tant
qu'autochtones l'histoire en général
parce que c'est quelque chose que je
voulais vraiment pas à prendre en étant
plus jeune c'est sûr que si j'avais
quelques petites histoires ici l'un des
grands parents m'ont dit vous savez
l'histoire générale d'un pensionnat
parce que justement ces tendances
environnement mes grands-parents
les traumatise secteur génère ce n'est
qu'un des pensées envers mes parents
mais je voulais commencer à voir plus
que vous jusqu'à tant qu'égérie fra qst
puis du moment que j comme compris
certaines choses sales comme fortifie
mon identité en tant que docteur alors
comment s'appelle cette école
autochtones wê vous je ne la connaissais
pas dites nous où elle est c'est
quelqu'un fait
l'essai s'appelle institution qui
menacent et dans la communauté
autochtone d'odanak hausse antiquités
qui sont environ 40 minutes de trois
rivières si je me souviens puis c'est
vraiment c'est une époque où va mieux
maintenant une semaine paris c'est c'est
écrit par paris pour notre fait mais qui
est ouvert à tous donc tout le monde est
la bienvenue dans l'état c'est sûr qu'à
travers les années plusieurs programmes
se sont comme ont été créés moi quand je
talent y avait tellement de programmes
en fait un programme universitaire plus
réussis aujourd'hui on note plusieurs
programmes puis je
sauvais sur l'expansion de lingots
justement parce qu'ils sont entendus qui
est beaucoup de progrès dans les studios
cela dit même fou si vous n'êtes pas
pratiquante non croyantes que cette
visite du pape finalement vous un
différé vous comprenez j'imagine que l
plus avoir fait du bien
des gens autour de vous exactement dix
mois que je vais poser la question à mes
grands parents ce que vous vous attendez
à quelque chose par rapport à l'acte et
tu vas plus haut qui m'ont dit non pas
au niveau personnel nous oh c'est pas
vraiment les mots qu'on attend c'est
plus les actions par rapport par rapport
à tout ce qui est arrivé dans les
pensionnats mais j'entendais le
témoignage d'autres lignes et puis non
besoin on avait besoin d entente pour
que notre processus de guérison commence
aujourd'hui sur ce que je ressens et ça
me laisse un peu différent parce que je
suis que ça va passer à partie à chaque
personne moi en tant que dj shop boys
jiji
la visite du pape comme étant une bonne
chose ou une mauvaise chose enfants tels
parce que je sais que chacun est
différent dans son processus de guérison
moi comme j'ai dit c'est elle que je
sais que ces mots un drop mais tout ce
que j'ai perdu à cause des traumatismes
j'ai un coucou on vous souhaite encore
de grandir de croître en beauté de
produire d'autres documentaires ou quel
que soit le moyen d'expression que je
choisirais ce sera pour notre bénéfice à
tous merci beaucoup
duchesne modèle je vous ai vu réagir
quand chaaouane coucou nous parlait
cette école autochtone ça a l'air
d'avoir été vraiment un moment crucial
dans sa vie
oui je ne connaissais pas l'histoire
halloween est juste ça vous démange
commun notre force notre président notre
volonté de vouloir dire à la planète on
y que papy sur le contrôle par de nous
cette volonté de briser le cycle de la
violence ou de la violence coloniale est
de savoir aussi que c'est le seul
collège autochtones au québec il a en
effet célébré son disant aux dames et
juste à côté de sorel à pierreville dans
ce coin-là nicolet et les la magic est
sorti de là depuis dix les dix dernières
années on a des avocats au cap des gens
qui vont rentrer en médecine des gens
qui sont entrepreneurs des gens qui
mobilise la société des gens qui sont
impliqués dans des organisations qu'une
influence ici au québec
envoyez vous comment cette force de
vouloir vous dire qu'on est capable
quand on est du bon monde hors jeu tout
est dit voir dans mon petit et des
parents
madame coton revenons là vous vous
demandez peut-être où se trouve le pape
il est temps rencontre privée en ce
moment avec des survivants de la
communauté ea nous que du nunavut donc
il les rencontre en privé on a pas
d'image de ça bien sûr ils les écoutent
qu'il les entend à présent on le
retrouvera à l'extérieur où on va lui
préparer une petite fête spectacle fait
culture inuite et spectacles au cours
duquel d'ailleurs il va lui même parlé
je veux revenir à ce qui se passe dans
le minas voûte ou dans les communautés
inuits avec madame coton on en a parlé
un petit peu avec marie-laure jocelyn
tout à l'heure de l'impact des
pensionnats dans ces communautés est
malheureusement en 1 voix de ces gens
dans les rues des grandes villes du
canada que ce soit en alberta que ce
soit à montréal ou à toronto
des gens il ya beaucoup de souffrance
beaucoup de toxicomanie
de tout de suicides effarant aussi
beaucoup de problèmes de santé mentale
en fait oui et beaucoup de ses problèmes
de santé mentale je dirais découlent
directement justement de trauma de la
colonisation et aussi de conditions de
vie qui sont toujours difficiles vous
savez moi quand je travaille au nunavik
et un tel problème de logement la boc
quand les gens veulent quitter un
conjoint violent physiquement c'est pas
toujours possible même s'ils ont pris la
décision de prisonniers de cet enfer
liste prisonnier de ce sens faire don
dans les gens qui s'exilent et qui
finissent itinérant montreal lieu
beaucoup de ceux de gens qui fuyaient
des conditions de vie intenables soit
par proximité avec un abuseur ou soit
parce qu'ils ont vécu vraiment des
choses difficiles et c'est pas évident
pour pour eux non plus quand arrive
c'est une telle différence culturelle
par exemple quand on quitte le numérique
on arrive à montréal
c'est il ya des problèmes de logement
aussi où il ya des problèmes de logement
aussi où les gens font quand même face à
toutes sortes de stéréotypes ce qu'ils
n'aiment pas ce qui n'aide pas non plus
il n'y a pas de service
tant que sade
organisé pour eux pour l'heure leur leur
bien-être dans l'installation en vue de
tous donc c'est des gens qui
qui font face à beaucoup de ce france
sur le plan de la santé mentale et a peu
de ressources est ce que est ce que la
population du nunavut où tu navigues
pour ce qui est du québec entend bon
accès aux soins de santé parce que j'ai
quelque part que parfois des problèmes
de langue ou si certains des services de
santé sont rendus dans une langue
l'anglais au français qu'il ne parle pas
nécessairement ils ont du mal à
expliquer leurs mots oui sont au niveau
des services qu'on donne en psychiatrie
ils ont accès à des interprètes
le problème avec les interprètes c'est
que ce sont des petites communautés de 2
500 600 personnes donc l'interprète est
toujours connu des jarres donc beaucoup
de gens font le choix de deux de plus
tôt par les soins en anglais ou en
français parce que ça devient malaise
entre le gft moulé en feuilles c'est
sera témoin est trop proche oui ça c'est
un des enjeux mais il ya aussi des
ressources qui manquent que je pense
qu'il devrait y avoir à la lumière des
difficultés qui sont présents beaucoup
plus de ressources d'hébergement pour
femmes en difficulté beaucoup plus de
ressources pour le traitement de de
l'abus de substances et de l'alcool
beaucoup plus de présence de
psychologues
on prendrait davantage prendrait bien
mon âge leur manque énormément et c'est
un taux de suicides qui est beaucoup
plus élevé que dans que la moyenne
nationale en fait beaucoup plus élevé en
fait le taux de suicide chez les
autochtones en général est plus élevé
que le taux national est le taux de
suicide chez les inuit est le plus élevé
parmi toutes les populations autochtones
c'est un des plus élevés au monde sinon
le plus élevé au monde et c'est la même
chose dans toutes les populations
inuites du globe je pense au groenland
par exemple j'imaginais ce que c'est
ils partagent tous une histoire de
pensionnat ou si c'est autre chose ou si
ils partagent une histoire de pensionnat
mais ils partagent aussi la colonisation
reviennent au delà des pensionnats parce
que même dans les communautés il y avait
des présences de missionnaires qui
quittent qui travaillait très fort pour
la conversion religieuse
qui démonise est tout ce qui était la
spiritualité autochtone et ça ça se
passait même dans les communautés inuit
le site est potable chéri boire kiki qui
les abusés sexuellement
j'en ai eu aussi des gens qui m'ont
raconté des abus sexuels de deux prêtes
mais c'était pas dans les pensionnats
donc ça s'est passé ailleurs aussi
c'était tout c'est elle le discours du
gouvernement qui invalide et leurs
savoirs par rapport à la santé par
rapport à l'éducation des enfants par
rapport à la à la gestion de leurs
affaires sociales donc ils ont été
critiqués inférioriser à tous les
niveaux où je dirais alain crevier vous
le disais tout à l'heure le pape a
valeur de bonne humeur il est on
le vus depuis le début de la semaine
quand il entre en contact avec les gens
probablement les gens qui souffrent ça
ça
se sent valorisé il a quelque chose à
apporter là quelque chose à donner ben
je sais pas c'est comme jean paul ii à
l'époque quand ils étaient très malades
y avait une sympathie évidente avec les
gens qui souffraient comme lui jean paul
doucet c'était vraiment un cas
particulier dans ce cas ci on voit que
le père françois a toute sa tête il est
très aisé c'est remarquable à chaque
fois qu'il entre en contact non pas avec
le protocole mais avec les gens qui
vient voir que ce soit les grands chefs
où que ce soit les inuit on le voit tout
de suite ils saluent et on voit qu'ils
content d'être là il ya et dans ses
discours ça paraisse à transpirer alors
je pense qu'ils étaient quand je vous
disais tout ça c'est une affaire de
présence c'est pas une affaire de mots
ils reposent jusqu'à où on passe on
aurait souhaité qu'il aille mais je
pense que ça passera à l'histoire à
cause de la présence d'un pape qui a été
sommée de se rendre au canada pour
s'excuser ce qu'il a fait je pense qu'il
aime ce contact là je regardais ce matin
à l'archevêché où il recevait des gens
je sais que ça va être un peu difficile
il ya des autochtones qui était pas
content de la manière qu'ils ont été
traités on aura peut-être le gâteau d'y
revenir un de ces jours mais je voyais
que il était là pour cette raison là où
ces gens là et j'ai ajouté un début de
semaine si ça peut intéresser de la
rappeler que c'est pas comme s'excuser
pour les croisades il a en face de lui
des gens qui veulent le voir il y en a
qui veulent être vus par lui mais il ya
une expérience physique qu'elle que
c'est de l'ordre du physique je pense
que c'est ce qu'on voit là et je sais
pas comment ça va se dérouler la fin de
l'après midi mais je pense que tout tout
se joue là et je pense quand il disait
ce matin je me sens un peu partie de
votre famille je n'ai pas juste la
coiffe que les touches à lui a donné oui
je pense qu'il voudrait ça en vous et
moi s'il fait partie de la famille la
question qui vient tout de suite après c
qu'est ce que c'est pour tes frères
étaient çà et là il va y avoir il va
devoir
mais j'imagine que dans sa qualité
d'écouté dans les petits gestes qu'ils
posent prendre mais embrasser celle d'un
autochtone survivants
sa qualité des coups tout ça c'est
important aussi dans sa façon dans la
façon d'être reçus par les survivants
qui
témoignent de leur souffrance c'est
évident il est pas ici pour prendre la
parole il est ici pour écouter c'est ce
qu'il avait dit qu'il ferait et je pense
que c'est ce qu'il fait ces remarques en
le souhaitent et en passant d'un chef
d'état qui pourrait occuper toute la
place vous avez quatre ans c'est via un
pack mobile y apprend la place il prend
tout cet espace là puis il y en a même
des bébés qui donne des bisous alors il
est capable de prendre cette place là il
le sait c'est un homme se nomme
quitterait qui de cette nature
c'est peut-être le grand intellectuel
que kate encore benoît 16 ou le
politicien quand je dis politiciens le
sais parce que je regardais cet
après-midi les vidéos de mes collègues
des années 80 87 en particulier en force
empson quand on décrivait jean paul ii
dans le grand danois et que je reparle
du 10 10 aux autochtones de la place je
vous encourage à revendiquer des
changements constitutionnels parce que
vous avez le droit à votre auto
détermination tout est vraiment les
pires politiques il ya même est ici à
autre chose on n'est pas dans l'été
lecture on est pas dans conceptuel on
n'est pas dans politique on est dans
l'humain et c'est sa force et c'est ce
qu'on a vu je pense à elle dans les
derniers jours je voulais avoir votre
votre trois pignons d'initiés d'une
certaine façon maligne dans le sens où
tous les deux on était en sang dimanche
on a suivi les discours de lundi mardi
puis vous à québec mercredi jeudi et se
et ce rajout r cette reconnaissance de
des abus sexuels commis par des membres
de l'église est ce que vous y voyez
quelqu'un justement qui a su écouter
ou bien changement politique
proposé par ses conseillers
c'est embêtant tout le monde se pose la
question mais j'ai relu le texte puis je
l'avais surlignés en trois couleurs mois
le texte et je me disais c'est tellement
remarquable parce que la chose la moins
remarquable c'est le fait qu'il parle
des abus sexuels parce que ça a déjà été
fait écouter tout le monde a parlé
d'être tous les trois derniers papes
n'ont parlé que de ça le plus le plus le
plus ardent là dedans je pensais bonnes
notes à chaque fois qu'ils sortent aide
du palais pontifical qui parlait de ça
il rencontré des victimes c'est pas ça
c'est pas les mots comme tel qui était
significatif c'est que ce sont des mots
qui était attendu par michèle audette
par exemple par un paquet de gens qui
attendaient ça mais dans le même
paragraphe mais trois couleurs de crayon
sont apparus parce qu'il parle de ça
ensuite il parle des autochtones et il
arrive à parler de cette espèce
d'impérialisme qui en porte un autre nom
de mensonges dans son arrogance ça
s'appelle de cléricalisme y est un
anticlérical ans même si l'impact est
dit tout de suite alors parler des abus
sexuels mais il faudra bien m'emmener
arrêté de s'imaginer que notre culture
est supérieur aux autres le groupe est
tout simplement les poser en écrasant
les coupes des cultures des autres fait
directement allusion évidemment à toute
cette tragédie pour lesquelles il est
venu au canada je trouve cela
remarquable dans ce petit paragraphe là
qu'il ya plusieurs idées qui est ce qui
cohabitent et qui sont tellement
importantes 9
alors
des commentaires là-dessus michel
peut-être
évidemment je n'ai je n'avais pas idée à
quoi pouvait ressembler la gouvernance
et la structure de de cette grande
église et j'ai beaucoup appris cette
semaine justement le temps du point de
vue il nous est de bien des gens qui
sont experts est de savoir que
finalement pour lui d'être très humains
ou des de vouloir juste ce matin on le
voit les images où est notre
représentant in où il n'était pas dans
la peut-être que les coins par les
caméras manon et caméras personnes
plutôt je devrais dire on le voit pas
évidemment le mocassin télégramme vient
vite à mes oreilles à que nenê s'est
perdue ne pas pas français ni anglais il
ne peut pas accepter de rencontrer à la
fin tout seul dans une pièce alors il
est parti de loin le nôtre et les deux
îles et le chamois soulagé je me suis
dit c'était son moment on l'a pas puni
parce qu'il s'est perdu et c'est vrai
vous avez raison alain c'était un homme
qui pense que qui a humanisé quelques
jours quelque chose qui nous est
déshumanisé pendant trop longtemps vous
savez ce matin il s'est passé quelque
chose dans beta c'est ses piques à
monsieur prix cassés jusqu'à qui raconte
à son père malade est assez fâché
d'ailleurs même pas beaucoup de place là
où où se réunissaient il y avait de la
place pour une vingtaine d'autochtones
pis ces dissidents mettre plus pourquoi
parce qu'il y avait une vingtaine de
membres du clergé des évêques et tout le
reste je sais pas si le pape s'est rendu
compte de ça parce que je devine qu'il
aurait il le répéter pas seulement
l'expression sortie de méchant en colère
c'est un anticlérical c'est quelqu'un
qui dit au clergé cassez vous vous
n'avez pas eu le pouvoir craint pas de
faire à revendiquer le pouvoir elle lui
venant de jésus temps plus de
m'intéresser mais alors je pense qu'il
aurait il aurait demandé à ce que ces
évêques face la place mais pour des
raisons que je comprends mal je bosse
iquique pas compris que tout ça tout ça
ça n'a qu'un but c'est de rencontrer des
autochtones limite 6 les premiers et
premières nations c'était seul but à la
manne et moi pas comment ça c'est qu'un
évêque ou qu'un clergé quelconque et
puisse imaginer qui avait sa place le
plus que les os mais ça ça me turlupine
mais j'ai comme l'impression qu'il a
nettement sa part les dents dans le
bonnet avant la fin de l'année oui parce
que des choses qui changent pas
décidément au nom écouter ya c'est
tellement c'était remarquable j'ai pas
pu faire autrement parce que dans ce
retard cette rencontre avec le clergé
tisser du staff le système staff meeting
comme on dit en anglais il rencontre son
clergé et je me disais ivre il va passer
ces avancées sur les bons latapie jeune
artiste lyrique à la il il a fait ça et
à la fin de son discours oui le dis
arrêtez vous imaginez que les gens sont
perdus c'est nous sommes perdus arrêtez
vous imaginez que tout va mal c'est nous
que sa marque pas alors il est vraiment
il donnait des pas seulement des
conseils mais des petits coups de volant
à droite et à gauche et qu'est ce que je
vois comme image alors là c'est très
intéressant et du clergé imaginez pas
que vous l'avez pouvoir et qu'est ce que
je vois de com image vous avez les
cardinaux en avant je suis vidé évêques
en arrière puis le reste dans le fond de
l'église hb c'est même dans la
disposition géographique la hiérarchie
de cette église est tellement plus
simple que ça finit par tuer le message
et c'est hier c'était s'était
partiellement intéressant mais
évidemment le petit paragraphe il était
question des abus sexuels et ensuite de
l'impérialisme de l'église c'est ça qui
l'emporté tant mieux d'ailleurs tant
mieux oui c'est ce qu'on a retenu puis
encore une fois comme vous dites c'est
sa présence et ses mollahs qui qu'on
retiendra et non pas le fait qu'ils
aient plus ou moins demande de wild
bunch nos stades ou juin sur les plaines
d'abraham nom à l'image que je vois là
je vous avais dit d'ailleurs ce sont les
images qui ont fait le tour du monde ça
va mais marquer si vous m'aidez m'a
donné dans un an google edmonton tape
françois regardez bien l'image que vous
allez voir apparaître ça va être celle
ce bar du lac cet engouement cas seuls
c'est un blanc dans son habit blanc
photo olympique web un peu voûté
cimetière c'est sûr que vous allez voir
apparaître ces des images très très fort
et on ne dira pas
où il y avait personne sur les plaines
d'abraham
mais ça ça dénote quand même autre chose
son état de la foi catholique au canada
mais ça c'est une autre histoire alors
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de ce
qu'il dira et qu'à lui et aujourd'hui
comme il le même modus operandi comme il
l'a fait dès maintenant comme il l'a
fait à québec il rencontre des aînés ils
rencontrent des survivants mais à quoi
s'attendre de plus mission à ce que vous
attendez vous avez obtenu hier cette
reconnaissance des abus sexuels dans les
pensionnats est-ce qu'il ya autre chose
que vous souhaitez entendre de la part
du pape
j'espère que cette fois ci les paroles
vont être devant les personnes alors que
hier soir les gens en train de manger
est en train de digérer toute cette
semaine et surtout la messe à la
basilique
où beaucoup s'attendaient à recevoir des
excuses mais bon ce faire plus intime et
astor là nous les gens n'étaient pas
c'est grâce à vous aux journalistes que
j'étais en mesure de voir le dico parce
que j'ai pas pensé mois halim branché
alors j'aimerais que cette fois ci c'est
comme quand il est venu la première
journée en alberta où là il les a fait
ses excuses même les gens voient très
applaudi au moment où les excuses
étaient prennent leur prononcé alors je
ne souhaite ça aussi à ical witt et si
je peux brièvement rassuré alain depuis
les tout débuts les groupes autochtones
des leaders les bénévoles des
communautés religieuses qui sont issus
d'une première nation métis et inuits
ont rappelé au clergé à l'église faites
nous confiance on veut mettre notre
couleur dans l'événement et ça a été
difficile et je pense qu'on le voit le
résultat alors l'enseignement je pense
après le départ du peuple c'est
peut-être de se rappeler et de leur
rappeler aux prêts et aux communautés
religieuses si on veut vraiment passer à
l'action peut-être qu'il faudrait faire
les choses ou ont ressenti qu'on est
impliqué dès le départ
maintenant quand on vous avez entendu
tout à leur chargement coucou nous
parler de ses réflexions au sujet de ce
que ses grands-parents vécu dans les
pensionnats de l'impact
intergénérationnelle du sentiment de
honte qu'il a déjà habité et où tu
duquel les passer
est ce que est ce que ça se comprend que
ça puisse prendre du temps à passer ou
de au delà de ce sentiment là et que la
visite d'un pape et ses mots aussi
agréable soit ils entendent sont une
part les d'agréables mais aussi ils font
du bien mais ce sont des processus très
long tout ça quand on parle de guérison
et de réconciliation
absolument il faut je pense qu'il faut
vraiment bien mesuré l'ampleur du
traumatisme est ce que ça implique comme
vitesse de guérison donc une générations
et des générations parce que le dernier
passionné au canada a fermé en 96 c'est
extrêmement récent et ç'a eu lieu
pendant pratiquement un siècle alors
c'est des générations de gens qui ont
été extrêmement blessé qui en subissent
les conséquences qu'ils essaient de
survivre à leur façon
de toutes sortes de façons parfois en
s'auto musquin avec des substances en
ayant des difficultés psychologiques qui
relève des traumatismes qu'ils ont vécu
donc ça ça peut se sentir sur des
générations parce que ça va influencer
les capacités parentales des gens qui
sont blessés d'une part quand on est
élevé dans un pensionnat on n'a pas de
modèle parental
adéquat
il ya eu toute les abus que l'homme et
même sans abus la structure
comportement'' analyse dans les
pensionnats beaucoup d'expansion avons
parlé d'un régime militaire extrêmement
dit je connaissais pas la maison tout à
fait quelque chose de très froid y avait
pas l'amour parental donc ça laisse des
séquelles et je pense qu'il faut être
très très la population générale
développer notre sensibilité et notre
compréhension que ces enjeux puisque le
gicleur ça prend des parfois des
générations arrêt paris et ce n'est pas
parce que si notre peuple a vécu la même
chose si on avait été comme francophones
envoyés dans des pensionnats anglophone
qu'on avait été
abusée qu'on avait été humilié dans ces
pensionnats là on serait pas plus rapide
le à ça au niveau de la guérison vers
moi j'ai jamais vu chez les autochtones
de toutes mes amies de pratiquer quelque
chose qui fait de l'ordre de dire de la
complaisance ou de la passivité là
dedans au contraire ils se mobilisent
pour essayer de guérir mais c'est alors
la vitesse semaine on peut pas pousser
un swing et les hauts de l'aude alors
c'est vraiment une volonté de guérir je
pense que ça pour beaucoup de gens
croyants c'est quelque chose qui peut
favoriser et que leur parole soit
entendue parce que beaucoup de jeunes
autochtones qui vont dire comme lg j'ai
intégré une honte d'être autochtone et
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le
colonialisme internaliser où le racisme
eternally c'est que qu'a pendant des
décennies un peuple en temps un discours
infériorisant à leur égard de dire vous
savez pas élever vos enfants vous savez
pas guérir les maladies vous savez pas
vous gérez comme peuple c'est le seul
discours colonial bas il fait disparaît
intégrer cette infériorisation loyers et
la voir à l'intérieur d'eux et ce traité
de cette façon là donc c'est très
complexe haut niveau ils attaquent
psychologique d'une histoire colonnes
parlons d'impact psychologique la visite
du pape au canada et tout ce que ça a
brassé ça aussi ça n'impacte que
j'exècre avoir un impact psychologique
positif mais ça peut avoir un impact
puisque le jeu négatif à court terme en
tout cas oui bon on a vu beaucoup
beaucoup dans les lignes des côtes pour
délit ressources mises psychologiques
mises à la disposition des pensionnaires
des ex pensionnaires des gens on a vu
les appels bondir le cette semaine donc
effectivement ça ça rappelle des
souvenirs traumatiques ça peut brasser
beaucoup choses je trouve ça bien que
les gens donnent de la place à ces
émotions là parce que même quand on
ressent quelque chose de dix minutes
pénibles ça peut quand même s'inscrire
dans un processus de guérison donc
l'important c'est que les gens restent
pas seuls avec cette souffrance l'eau en
parle que ce soit leurs proches ou linde
écoute à des professionnels pour que
justement en faisant ça je pense que ses
émotions le pourrait participer au
processus de guérison donc en d'autres
mots même si ç'a brassé que c'est
douloureux il vaut mieux que ça
s'exprime oui c'est ce concile pas
absolument psychologie on pense que les
traumas que les gens puissent en parler
puissent être reçus avec compassion avec
écoute sans jugement
ça c'est quelque chose qui a de la
gueule et ça ça s'adresse à nous tous ah
ben si tu ne l'as pas
retrouvons maintenant charles le
bourgeois il est original charles a
suivi la délégation autochtone qui était
au vatican en avril dernier mais depuis
vous êtes de retour au pays vous avez
rencontré plusieurs survivants lors du
passage du pape dans l'ouest à edmonton
quelques qu'est ce que vous retenez de
ce de ce son séjour en alberta
je retiens une certaine logique en fait
un certain continuum d'abord dans la
nature de ce voyage un pèlerinage
pénitentielle alors par ces mots on
comprend d'abord qu'il ya un désir de la
part de l'église de prendre sa
responsabilité dans les crimes qui ont
été commis dans les dans les pensionnats
pour autochtones ensuite les excuses du
pape à masquer witches lundi dernier
humblement je demande pardon pour le mal
qui a été commis par des chrétiens dans
les airs contre les peuples autochtones
alors évidemment après ses excuses
certains ont estimé que ce n'avait pas
été assez loin ils ont regretté
notamment que le pas françois elle n'est
pas dénoncer les abus sexuels dans les
pensionnats ils ont été entendus puisque
in air à québec le pape françois a
demandé pardon pour les abus sexuels
commis contre les mineurs et contre les
personnes vulnérables de la part du
clergé canadien et puis le pape françois
s'est également inspiré il a voulu
rendre hommage à la culture autochtone
et en particulier aux aînés aux grands
parents il a expliqué que c'était eux
elle les gardiens du savoir que ce sont
tout petits transmettre les traditions
et il a eu un fils rouges durant ce que
tous ceux tous tout ce voyage du pape au
canada c'était sa manne sainte-anne
qu'il a voulu honorer et d'ailleurs
c'est important de donner le temps
françois en rappelant l'importance des
grands parents aussi évoqué sa grand
mère parce que c'est elle qui l'a éduqué
dans la foi et c'est grâce est qu'il est
devenu
je vous interromps parce que j'aimerais
qu'on écoute les chants de gorge c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'important a
qu'une seule nuit écoutons l'est
[Rires]
[Musique]
m
à
et
alors je crois que ces dames qui chante
qu'on voit à droite s'appelle acquis ni
6 ivoire à pic elle a d'ailleurs
remporté le prix de l'artiste de l'année
au nord du québec
donc on a pas on dit on parle de chant
de gorge mais en fait apparemment ce
sont plus des jeux de gorges sont des
histoires qu'elle raconte qu elle se
raconte son histoire qui sont dédiées à
la nature ça peut être le passage vol
d'oiseau des oies ça pète dix jours sur
la banquise et c'est un jeu parce que la
première qui se trompe ou qui n'a plus
de souffle ou qui ou qui chante de
travers c'est elle qui a perdu et puis
on recommence on recommence à chanter
c'est une tradition essentiellement
féminine que les femmes
perpétuent est à la maison
dans leur igloo une fois les maris
partis à la chasse est une fois les
tâches domestiques terminé on va les
écouter encore
[Musique]
et à travers ce champ c'est aussi
justement le
la force de la culture inuite parce que
pendant la colonisation
ces chants de gorge était interdite
alors qu'aujourd'hui les femmes inuites
et retrouver renouer avec ce champ avec
cette tradition avec ce jeu c'est de
dire au monde
la force de leur culture qu'elle est
bien vivante
moi j'espère qu'elle aura encore un
autre
alors voilà je vais retrouver mon
collègue charles le bourgeois qui a eu
la patience d'attendre mais je suis sûr
que c'était pas pénible car vous avez
profitez vous aussi des chants de gorge
inuit n'est ce pas
avec mais j'ai profité de ce beau
spectacle et en même temps que je
regardais ces images je ne pouvais
m'empêcher de me souvenir de ce que nous
demande et en exhortant à sion le pack
françois il nous disait face à ce drame
des crimes qui ont été commis dans les
pensionnats quel est notre réaction à
nous est ce que on nous entendant ça et
nous sommes comme des personnes
curieuses et mondaine ou bien est-ce que
l'on s'offusque et danseuses scandalise
mais ça s'arrête là où est ce que au
contraire nous ayons nous essayons de
faire quelque chose de concret pour
tenter de les aider dans leur chemin de
guérison et de réconciliation alors je
pense que c'est clairement tout à chacun
de faire recette de réflexion au
françois oui alors vous avez suivi
d'autres visites pas passer ces dons
nous sommes clairement interpellé comme
société dans son ensemble c'est vrai
charles vous vous avez suivi d'autres
visites papales ou cours des années
alors comment comment celle-ci se
distingue-t-elle des autres
c'est vrai qu'en général dans ses
voyages apostoliques le pape françois
vient à la rencontre du peuple de dieu
c'est à dire qu'il vient affermir la
fois chez les chrétiens là la nature de
ce voyage est différent parce qu'il nous
faut encore le pape vient en pèlerinage
pénitentielle ce sont ses mots il vient
s'excuser pour le mal que l'église
elle-même a commis pendant ce temps dans
les pensionnats pour autochtones et
c'est intéressant de noter qu'en général
le pape dans ses voyages commencent
d'abord par rassembler les chrétiens
pour une messe solennelle qui démarre ce
voyage là le peuple est arrivé dimanche
dernier il n'a pas célébré la messe et
pourtant on était dimanche il s'est
d'abord excusé lundi pour le mal commis
par l'église catholique et c'est le land
seulement le lundi que le pape au stade
du commonwealth a retrouvé la communauté
chrétienne en plus des survivants des
pensionnats pour célébrer la messe donc
on voit clairement qu'il ya une une
ambiance qui est différente une ambiance
beaucoup plus sobre ça a été le cas en
alberta ça c'est lui et puis aussi au
québec il ya huit aujourd'hui où
certainement le pape françois devrait
interroger les lélés les survivants mais
aussi elle et les descendants de
survivants pour qu'il prenne en main la
culture autochtone qui a été vraiment au
coeur des discours du pape depuis le
début de son voyage au canada
charles bourgeois merci beaucoup d'avoir
témoigné tout ça pour nous
renvoie
alors retournons sur ces images en
direct di canio capitale du nunavut du
territoire indépendant du nunavut qui
les territoires seulement depuis 1993 ça
a été le fruit d'une négociation avec le
gouvernement fédéral un territoire peu
peuplé territoire où la population est
très jeune il ya énormément de jeunesse
enfin pas beaucoup d'aînés spa nous au
pouvoir témoigner en coton vous qu'il y
allait souvent au nunavik c'est la même
courbe démographique la moitié de la
population a moins de 18 ans le taux de
natalité plus élevé que dans la
population générale et
là les problèmes touchent tous les âges
y compris cette très jeune jeunesse
finalement absolument mieux par exemple
au nunavik eeyou quand je demande aux
gens vous que vous avez combien de
proches qui se sont suicidés la moyenne
comme on dit c'est 3 à 4
3 4 par famille par personne ça faisait
quatre personnes connaît au moins trois
ou quatre autres personnes qui se sont
suicidées c'est énorme c'était une arme
ça ça touche tous les âges
alors je vous rappelle que le pape est
toujours en train de rencontrer des
survivants inuits survivants des
pensionnats ce que la foule pendant ce
temps-là
assiste à un spectacle
le pape devrait arriver sous peu on
l'attend
très bientôt
une doit d'ailleurs prononcé un 10e
acte i mois sans
lui
washington
à
[Musique]
oignies
bravo
je
m
oui
où
[Musique]
cet humour
m
être promu bon
tous
on nous dit m
sow
ce match
giuly
et vous
[Musique]
shadows même usage
i
chaouch
[Musique]
fonçant à
nouveau banni ce crâne chine cherchait
enfin la skull fils
[Musique]
et
et marc nabitz y sont
chinatown
[Musique]
pis
soumis à l'avis
de tous et
nous le ferons
[Musique]
la dune
mais bon
non
m
amour
[Musique]
stitch
ce match
ici
[Musique]
maggie grace où il joue
[Applaudissements]
lisandro est
écrit je pensais d'où venons nous tous
mais de qui venons nous et que sommes
nous censés faire dans cette vie quel
que soit notre parcours comment
sommes-nous liés les uns avec les autres
et comment devrions-nous nous honorer
les uns les autres et nous soutenir les
uns les autres quoi qu'il advienne
il n'y a rien que nous puissions
achever quand nous croyons en nous mêmes
car nous savons d'où nous venons et
quand nous travaillons ensemble
j'espère que vous allez apprécier cette
chanson voilà la chanson de la vie
[Musique]
m
ah oui
oui oui
moi tout suivant
autre grand moment
les
ministres
occupants
et nous qui nous fait trop en nous
du
c'est tout
[Musique]
ça
on est des normes before
[Musique]
il est chez nous et nous faut
jours
[Musique]
kevin thau minimes
si vous dites
toumani qui sony
n'entend leurs outils
[Musique]
et que nos matches entre 9 ans
double
non
qui était très moyen
sow
nailloux me larguer si bonne idée me
caille psaume aniki ciani n'est pas tant
la petite
je
[Musique]
youpi
m
[Musique]
ryan la mi-mars et à l'octet manica six
véhicules sur match remercie énormément
de tracy présent
quelle journée
merci un an free fantastique artistes
qui illustrent notre formidable culture
avec fierté
pour ceux et celles d'entre vous
qui portent des écouteurs pour entendre
mon interprétation n'oubliez pas de les
ramener
de que nous aurons terminé
vous pouvez donc utiliser le matériel
d'interprétation
je veux demander de faire preuve de
patience nous attendons encore l'arrivée
du pauvre pas peur françois
est accompagné des survivants qui sont
en train de le rencontrer alors que je
vous parle et
nous attendons davantage at il
donc le poste ne devrait plus tarder des
cela eh bien nous allons tendre
davantage d'artistes
alors oui on nous apprend on nous
confirme en fait que le pape françois
satin de prend tout le temps de discuter
avec ces survivants kid est en train de
rencontrer en privé on a vu pendant ce
temps la foule être
distraite amusé divertit plus tôt par
par ces artistes inuit chanteur de gorge
on a entendu tout à l'heure une
chanteuse d'opéra et en fait la seule
chanteuse classique si on veut il nous
que du pays elle a déjà enregistré
d'ailleurs des disques dont elle nous
parlait cette scène que l'on voit est
censé être à l'image
d'une scène d'un cas mac ça s'appelle un
cas max et une maison d'été tels que les
inuits ce la bâtisse et qui reflète les
matériaux de construction traditionnelle
était bien sûr nous quand on pense aux
inuits on pense à e-loue donc à des
blocs de glace et de neige mêlées t il
avait des des maisons comme ça
construite à partir de ce qu'ils
trouvaient c'est à dire les côtes de
baleines du gazon et des pierres et
cette scène donc se veut à l'image de ce
qui s'appelle le camaq alors pendant
qu'on attend le pape je crois que les
artistes inuit vont probablement
remonter sur scène pris de court mais
aussi par ce léger changement de
programme le pape qui était pourtant
parti avec de la vence à québec nous qui
devions commencer de cette émission à
16h30 l'avons commencé plus tôt
mais voilà il prend je crois qu'il a
profité de ce temps gagné sur le départ
pour le passer plus longtemps avec les
survivants et c'est ainsi que on
apprendra comment tout ça c'est passé
des gens qui avaient énormément besoin
de le rencontrer
que ce soit
pour l'entendre s'excuser ou simplement
pour se raconter e dire ce qu'ils ont
vécu et je pense qu'ils ont en face
d'eux un homme qui s'est montré plutôt
compatissant je pense qu'on peut dire ça
sans se tromper alors on le voit on est
on est dans cette capitale du nunavut je
crois qu'il fait juste 12 degrés
aujourd'hui on se rend pas compte ici
c'est l'été presque caniculaire mais
c'est la région la plus froide sinon une
des régions les plus froides du pays
l'hiver est très long et très très très
froid on parle de -30 degrés parfois
encore plus froid c'est un
une région du pays qu'il vante aussi
très fort il ya énormément de bizarre ce
qui contribue à accentuer la sensation
de froid et pourtant notre courageuse
marie-eve coton il va régulièrement
hiver comme été madame côté de
fréquences qui va je vais livrer aussi
qu'est ce qui vous a attiré pourquoi
pratiquer votre métier de psychiatre là
j'avais commencé moi par faire de la
coopération internationale dans des pays
en voie de développement aux philippines
république dominicaine et j'étais très
touché par les inégalités sociales que
je voyais les autres jouets des gens
avec toute évidence des conditions de
vie
pas du tout semblable à celle dans
laquelle moi j'avais grandi et je
voulais m'orienter pour faire une
carrière à médecins sans frontières et
travailler à l'étranger mais j'ai eu la
curiosité d'aller à celle subie à la
baie james pendant mon cours de médecine
et j'ai vu l'autre et inégalités
sociales aussi importante que ce que
j'avais vu à l'étranger et j'étais très
intriguée par le silence qui entourait
ça c'est à dire de je me demandais
comment collectivement on pouvait en
parler aussi peu
houleux prioriser eu si peu
malgré tout ça donc je me suis dis que
j'irai à l'étranger quand des
autochtones auraient les mêmes
conditions de vie que les blancs
créateur c'est ce que doit être le
chlore encore mieux encore alors vous
allez rester avec eux travailler avec
eux je les travaille avec eux ou ou si
longtemps je vais pouvoir c'est un
engagement un attachement
je suis très touché par ce qui parce
qu'ils ont vécue par leur résistance par
leur façon très pacifique de faire face
à l'injustice aussi donc pour moi
c'était je vais continuer tant que ce
sera nécessaire et que je vais être
capable on parlait avec vous tout à
l'heure de l'impact sur la santé mentale
des communes de ces communautés la de
l'impact des pensionnats et on parlait
de l'itinérance envies leurs conditions
de vie il a connu la pac de la
colonisation général leurs conditions de
vie qui les amène à fuir vers la ville
pour se retrouver michèle audette dans
des conditions envie qu'ils sont pas
faciles et je pense que cela vous
préoccupe beaucoup l'itinérance
autochtone dans les villes
attendez je vois là allez-y votre micro
était et elle a été fermée à l'isi
merci oui beaucoup parce que en personne
est à l'abri
j'ai un fils de 28 ans qui habite à
vancouver et je lui disais que j'avais
été à vancouver à l'âge de 16 ans et
j'avais été frappé par le d'antan
message commun une communauté autochtone
divers dans la rue et comme commissaire
plus tard en 2008 leur 2019 salle avait
augmenté donc on pense que c'était moi
tout d'abord c'est surtout dans l'ouest
et montréal commencez à avoir beaucoup
beaucoup de visages qui sont familiers
pour moi que je peux associé à une
nation ou un territoire jusqu aux dépens
de notre frère
raphaël andré de schefferville qu'on va
retrouver ma vie mais alors on a donné
un chapitre à la ville mon conjoint et
moi et c'est devenu une tente dans les
normes en plastique un chapiteau pendant
deux ans à nourrir d'emily jane est
tellement con étaient accueillants pour
moi mais les innu les mots et les
nations qui travaillait là toutes les
cultures confondues pouvait manger et
des milliers de personnes ont bénéficié
de notre amour notre générosité mais
c'est peut-être encore un long cycle est
partout partout au canada puis ça ça où
c'est un sérieux problème mais pourquoi
michel qu'est ce qui arrive pourquoi
comment se fait-il qu'on en soit là
pour se rappeler que c'est pas un choix
on s'envoie pas d'enjeu dans pensant que
je sais largement vga je suis normal
depuis des millénaires mais c'est pas ce
type de nomadisme que je recherche et
marie-eve votes exprimés très bien de
pourquoi on re quitter pour des raisons
de santé de sécurité de santé mentale ou
à la recherche d'un mieux être
lorsqu'on arrive dans sud on a aussi une
barrière système et qu'on a aussi à
certains endroits un racisme une
discrimination ou des biais inconscient
j'ai habité longtemps à montréal j'ai
habité longtemps montréal et je vais
remarquer souvent battu parle pas
français je peux pas de desservir ici
c'est en français où les autochtones
babel va voir le fédéral il ya eu des
situations même et tout récemment sitv
va faire un reportage on va voir de
jeunes femmes qui travaillent dans le
domaine de la santé à montréal et une
collègue aussi qui va m'expliquer que
j'amène des personnes à l'hôpital et
l'hôpital refusent ou les endroits où on
exposait d'être protégé des trousses
médico légales qui sont pas offerts puis
parce qu' elle ne parle pas le français
où elles sont autochtones où on a des
projets donc ça existe encore en vain 22
à montréal il a ça morial et d'autres
villes à lier et yoyo cette
méconnaissance sera six ce malaise les
billets qui fait qu'il ya un amalgame
qui fait comme vous l'avez dit marielle
on se retrouve qu'on n'a pas
nécessairement la même réaction sociale
ou le la même réponse sociale ou les
mêmes services alors qu'est-ce qui fait
vous avez parlé de l'initiative de votre
initiative et celle de votre conjoint de
septembre mais ça n'a duré qu'un temps
il n'y a toujours pas de solution
pérenne notre monde ça ne va pas être
simple à régler non plus non les
solutions elles sont là il y à des
organisations qui sauvent des vies des
organisations à montréal et dans
d'autres régions qui accompagnent les
vies des fois il ya un stock un statu
quo politique des fois il ya une
méconnaissance des fois c'est pas ma
priorité c'est pas dans ma cour s'il
vous plaît il ya une multitude de
raisons qu'elle soit politique
économique ou tout simplement je sais
pas moi de faire ça qu'on se retrouve à
la merci ou très très loin dans les
priorités est ce que est ce que vous
diriez que ça va en augmentant ce
problème depuis l'accueil depuis le
sénat est on est on est dans un endroit
ou à tous les jours je côtoie d'aider
des gens de différentes nations c'est
par tous et à montréal à québec ça
commence et dans d'autres villes et ont
dit pourquoi autant de gens qui se
retrouvent et souvent
les préjugés auxquels on en parle mais
là que vit devons nous avoir fait
beaucoup beaucoup mal et la nouvelle
forme où l'ancienne mais qui de plus en
plus de connu qui est une itinérance
nomades je dois dormir chez un sur un
divan chez un ami ou chez une
connaissance et si tu scapin j'ai
utilisé toutes mes ressources et qu'est
ce qui me reste les organisations sont
surpeuplées sous financée alors il me
reste la rue
est ce que dans donc pour pour ce qui
est du nunavut
une crise du logement nous disaient mes
rêves coton tout à l'heure et on se dit
qu'ils manquent de logements là bas il
ya manque si en ville ça ne va pas aider
à régler ce genre de problème mais je me
demandais si il ya toutes sortes de
problèmes dans les communautés éloignées
et certaines communautés autochtones on
parle de problèmes d'eau potable on
parle de problèmes de logement ils sont
multiples autant de raisons n'est ce pas
mutuelle pour amener les jeunes sans
doute avec les quitter leur comité peut
à partir pour la ville
certainement beaucoup de gens en pensent
trouver meilleur ailleurs et pour
arriver à ajouter une ou plusieurs
couches de réalité qu' on n'a pas
nécessairement imaginer ou voulu qu'on
voulait rappelons-nous aussi souvent je
vais entendre des gens plus il faut être
de bonne foi du coup vous quittez pas
vos communautés pour ghost un ghetto
pourquoi vous restez là bas le labo
aussi il ya des références millénaire le
labour s'il ya une connexion spirituelle
une fierté une fois on prend le
processus de guérison une fois qu'on l'a
su qu'on a le droit d bien qu'on se
donne les moyens pourraient bien
les plus simples possibles jusqu'à les
complexes possible il fait que moi je
laime montmagny utenam je veux pas qu'on
l'appelle réserve qu'on l'appelle ou est
ce que lis nous est protégé par sa
langue sa culture son identité et lui
protège sa langue sa culture et son
identité et qu'après son que le
transporter partout et c'est pas juste
dans une petite communauté où une grande
communauté il faut que ce soit partout
en pour moi ça les gens ont droit
d'habiter où ils veulent habiter il faut
s'assurer qu'on a nous aussi des droits
on a on devrait avoir les mêmes
standards internationaux canadien ou
québécois et c'est pas juste dans le sud
qu'on doit avoir ses standards de ville
c'est peu importe le lieu de résidence
ce n'est ni assez complexe et coûteux
oui mais on ya droit donc bien sûr
diriez vous que vous fil des années où
ces dernières années parce qu'on voit
émerger entre dans les médias nous
sommes pointés du doigt a montré du
doigt nous les médias dans la commission
vérité réconciliation nous avons
participé à ce système une certaine
façon on ne le dénonce en panne en
véhiculant des préjugés racistes contre
notre gré chose de pensé mais cela dit
on n'y a contribué mais on voit à
travers les médias de plus en plus des
personnalités comme vous comme roméo
saganash on a vu une mairie mason
devenir gouverneur général du canada on
suit de près ce qui se passe à
l'assemblée des premières nations on a
suivi les commission denquête elles se
sont multipliées au fil des années
diriez vous que tous à
contribuer à la guérison contribuer à la
réconciliation
définitivement ainsi on se retrouve avec
une enquête nationale sur les femmes et
filles autochtones associés disparu les
médias traditionnels comme les médias
sociaux ou les mouvements qu'on retrouve
dans les réseaux sociaux vont avoir fait
une pression importante significative
auprès de tous les partis politiques
alors c'est ce que c'était à l'agenda
d'une campagne électorale
et si les médias avait été silencieux
comme ce qu on a été habitué de voir ou
qu'on va dénoncer ou quand on est comme
aby en train pour acquis qu'ils voudront
pas je suis moi je le sais dans mon
coeur qu'on leur ait pas eu cette
enquête en 2005 les peut-être elle
serait peut-être arriver plus tard le
fait que notre soeur joyce et chaque
coin va donner ces dernières secondes
sur son téléphone cellulaire
dire une vérité vous la vie ramassé que
vous l'avez repris peu importe le médium
le média ou le réseau les réseaux
sociaux bien ou mauvais mais ça fait le
tour de la planète en quelques secondes
alors il ya des moments où grâce aux
médias on est capable de comparer que
l'histoire est mieux raconter où elle va
faire réagir correctement
une situation qui est inacceptable et
qui va aider à corriger ça là dessus
faux faux pour se donner que lorsqu'on
fait les choses ensemble ou avec je vous
écoute comment vous présenter les gens
et kalou et comment vous les nommez
comment vous expliquer les choses
comines où je savais même pas je pensais
que c'était une igloo mais je la
trouvais pas mal brune voyez plutôt on
apprend même de ton au top ben oui mais
environ et et on est en apprentissage
constant je peux vous dire parce que on
découvre aussi la bis de notre ignorance
sait on en est vraiment là je pense
c'est c'est ça cela dit de votre vivant
avoue michel vous êtes tous des jeunes
dans le fond mais est ce que vous
pourriez dire qu'il ya eu du progrès
déjà dans dans le retour à soi dans la
fierté de soi dans la fierté d'être truc
tonnes au cours de votre vie ce que vous
avez vu
voyez-vous du progrès oui oui je crois
que c'est marié qui a parlé de
2,7 en août comme beaucoup de gens vont
l'avoir dit on avait en parce qu'on nous
enseigne est d'être des bons à rien qui
ont le cul qu'on était des bons à rien
puis que c'était une telle et normaliser
cette violence là où rester dans le
tableau et le 13 juillet je devais
envoyer après un an et demi de malaise
mon formule 1 pour une compensation ou
actionnaires externes
ou faisait lourd d'émotion parce que dès
mon histoire mais
le vécu et le lent mais on célébrait une
entente historique avec 22 communautés
des premières nations à gallargues et où
j'ai vu des jeunes prend le micro et
parler que dans leur langue mon me
l'enlève on m'empêche de l'honorer puis
de la faire vibrer et plusieurs années
plus tard on voit tout c'est relève
l'ofdt comme la gêne de qui nous a parlé
de son de son film ils sont et s on
vient ils marchent droit et toi alors
pour moi c'est de la guérison pur
l'appui de la fierté ouais c'est ça la
crise d'oka a été d'ailleurs assez
important dans cette espèce de prise de
conscience collective
n'est ce pas oui là on n'avait pas les
réseaux sociaux on avait pas internet
comme et les gens apprenaient que c'est
pas des amérindiens c'est pas des
indiens c'est des mohawks des innus et
des attikameks on réalise que plusieurs
nations on réalise que les nations
n'avait jamais arrêté de dire nous
étions ici et nous sommes encore ici
voilà pourquoi on se on se tient debout
pour défendre ce qui reste du territoire
alors il ya une paix des gâtines
pédagogie assez intense qui a mine comme
si on voyage dont
vous parliez de longue date automne ces
jeunes qui aujourd'hui tiennent tout
tout tout un événement dans leur langue
mais ces langues autochtones elles ne
sont pas enseignées elles ne sont pas
encore assez utilisé il y avait des
recommandations des appels actions de la
commission vérité réconciliation à cet
égard oui oui il ya des langues qu'on a
tendance à dire moche alors qu'elle
dorme on va voir des nations vouloir
ramener six et à gallargues et
j'apprenais encore on apprend chaque
jour kühl dans les années où on va
arriver avec la loi 101 au québec ça va
mais de l'énergie et beaucoup de
pouvoirs pour la communauté de galons à
guérir
lorsque le faut que je mette en place
une école où je vais en scène enseigner
le cas d'un gag le maroc et de l'art
plusieurs générations vont passer par là
et ramène la langue mon mac imaginez
pour nous ceux et celles qui sont
capables de participer à cette entente
historique on va pouvoir l'adapter à la
langue ici doit on voit la réveiller
pour assurer qu'elle soit vivante encore
à d'autres endroits elle est en train
décembre on va mettre d'autres
initiatives et ainsi de suite et à la
manière des gens et à la vie à la
vitesse des gens dans les milieux ce
pour moi c'est un cadeau qu'on se fait
mais c'est aussi une obligation est un
droit ouais je vois les images toujours
en direct mesdames messieurs de 10 cas 8
capitale du nunavut où se trouve le pape
françois ultime étape de son voyage au
canada
par françois qui devait parler si je ne
m'abuse il ya déjà quoi une quinzaine de
minutes attendez que la régie me
confirme le tout oui c'est non 17h30 il
devait parler maintenant alors il y là
il a du retard
on sait qu'il était en rencontres
privées avec des survivants
faut croire que cette rencontre se passe
dès qu'elles se prolongent peut-être
qu'elle est très émouvante et que chacun
de reprendre ses esprits on ne le sait
pas on sera fixé dans quelques temps
marie-eve côte on parlait tout à l'heure
de l'accès pour les gens de
la voûte vous travaillez au nunavik
territoire québécois inuits mais où
l'accès l'accès aux soins de santé pour
être difficile pour certains et
certaines populations qui ne parlent que
leur langue autochtone mais pour ce qui
est du nunavik trévoux qui parle
majoritairement leur langue ou s'il
parle anglais et où le français à la
maison ils vont parler majoritairement
line où tout est vrai ils sont
scolarisés en inuktitut que jusqu'à le
troisième année du primaire
inclusivement et ensuite ils ont le
choix entre le français et l'anglais la
majorité de la population à l'anglais
comme langue seconde parce que ce sont
des missionnaires ang lee qu'un
anglophone qui sont arrivés là en
premier il ya eu aussi une présence a
demandé de l'armée américaine winter oui
alors tout se fait en sorte parce que
les gens souvent je trouve au québec ont
l'impression que quand les nations le
l'anglais ou le français comme langue
seconde et il voit une espèce
d'allégeance dans les conflits
francophone anglophone alors que c'est
vraiment l'histoire des contacts
historique entre alors il ya des groupes
autochtones qui vont avoir le français
comme langue seconde
pour des raisons historiques et d'autres
l'anglais mais ça ça va parfois heurter
des sensibilités au niveau des ddd
québécoise met donc à la maison ils vont
parler leur langue maternelle mais dans
le langage de tous les jours dans les
commerces ou dans l'administration
publique ou dans le domaine de la santé
les travailleurs entre eux vont parler
l'anglais au français oui ça se passe
majoritairement en anglais les gens dont
vont parler aux médecins aux infirmières
en anglais et puis ils ont tous accès à
une interprète ça leur est offert par
contre la majorité des crimes d'une part
je dois être leur anglais très bon donc
ils sont très bons en anglais et d'autre
part il ya des enjeux de confidences ce
sont des petites communautés aussi pour
se rendre compte qu'on le pense cc je
pense que lui et ses sept huit mille
habitants
sont pas très nombreux et il a beaucoup
plus bien sûr dans le nunavut mais pour
ce qui est de la capitale c'est cette
fumée l'habitant et c'est la même chose
donc dans le nunavik au québec vous
n'avez que la plus grosse ville ses
coûts de joie qu'elle est un peu plus de
2000 je crois donc c'est pas des grosses
communautés les autres communautés ça
tourne plus autour de 600 700 800
personnes oui on disait vous mentionniez
il ya eu effectivement une présence une
base militaire américaine est il qu'à
lui et c'est évidemment la ville une
ville très très nordiques il y a eu
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale les
américains il y en avait fait une base
militaire de deux d'escale si vous
voulez de transport
vers le terrain de terrain de guerre
vers l'europe et puis c'est aussi fait
partie je pense que c'était une ligne de
défense radar
dans le cadre d'une morale de ce traité
de défense nord américain qui passait
par là donc a eu effectivement une
présence militaire américaine ce n'est
plus qu'en maintenant en ma connaissance
mais qu'a longtemps et est présente dans
cette ville capitale du nunavut
alors on voit la foule je sais pas la
pâleur de s'impatienter je voyais des
gens utiliser leur téléphone et je me
demandais où on était l'état d'internet
dans cette zone nordique est ce que les
gens est un bon accès internet à votre
connaissance ne rêvent que ton on a des
problèmes techniques avec l'internet ça
aussi je dirais qu'avec le logement
c'est un autre enjeu où il faudrait de
façon urgente d'investissement au
nunavik parce que il ya internet
mais il ya beaucoup de problèmes
techniques beaucoup de lenteur donc ce
soit au niveau de l'éducation au niveau
de la santé c'est un outil qui est au
coeur de la modernité la modernité donc
de gmt j'ai plusieurs patients qui
choisissent ne pas me voir par écran
mais qu'on se parle au téléphone parce
que la qualité de l'internet l'image
crise gl je dis donc
on a ces problèmes-là donc
l'accessibilité aux soins et les cours à
distance par exemple le plein chose qui
socialement irait mieux si elle un peu
plus d'investissement dans la dimension
technique aux dynamiques on le sait
aussi les canettes a vécu des problèmes
d'accès à l'eau potable il n'y a pas
très longtemps il ya quelques mois où
les sources d'eau potable étaient
contaminés aux hydrocarbures on parle de
pétrole parce que c'est une région aussi
où il ya du pétrole
questionné pour le nunavik au québec est
ce que l'accès à l'eau potable comment
ça va non à coup de joie par exemple oui
l'accès en fait qui est souvent des
repas on nous recommande nous les
professionnels qui arrivons là de faire
bouillir toujours loup ce qui se passe
c'est que l'une à vic le sound et gèle
pas même l'été donc ya pas de tuyau
dames seules ces des réservoirs qui sont
collés sur les maisons l'extérieur qui
sont remplis une fois par semaine des
camions par le camion de la transporte
tout est fait et c'est recommandé de la
ddt
donc de la mer point d'ébullition avant
de la boire donc c'est une difficulté de
plus à la vie quotidienne s'est pas
c'est pas aussi pire que certaines
communautés au canada où vraiment le
lieu d avis d'ébullition constant depuis
des années et moi je peux toujours pas
comprendre qu'on tolère cela au canada
mais je vous dirais que la vie ou
nunavik le partisan bouche comme ceux
quotidienne elle est quand même le plus
parce que c'est vrai michèle audette
compte à l'heure depuis longtemps que
plusieurs communautés n'est pas accès à
l'eau potable vous en connaissez
sûrement vous même d'ailleurs
oui oui plus très loin de toi ou
une communauté près de val-d'or kittisak
et qui va y avait comme une célébration
dans les réseaux sociaux que elle va
être branché à hydro québec
alors que vous l'avez bien mentionné une
grande patience parce que ça fait depuis
des décennies que je capote au courant
depuis toujours et d'électricité alors
on est au québec à vous pouvez imaginer
maintenant travers le canada
des endroits où les les espaces où on
veut purifier l'eau pour que les maisons
puissent avoir de l'eau potable sont
désuets et lol le débat à la province de
fédérale et la communauté pendant ce
temps là bas les gens ont des maladies
des maladies qu'on retrouve beaucoup
dans ces régions là parce que l'eau est
contaminée est donc des études qui se
font au sénat pour essayer de trouver
des solutions et des études qui se font
à travers le canada qui prouve encore
une fois que comme un suspect qui si on
n'a pas pourtant la vie rivière de l'eau
et de l'eau potable et qu'on n'ait pas
accès ça et il a réponse michel louvain
tu mets autre outre une espèce de
peut-être d'indifférence de négligence
c'est aussi pas facile d'amener de l'eau
dans certaines communautés
c'est coûteux c'est pas facile ou
ou peut-être que le fait qu'on n'a pas
pris soin de l'infrastructure au fil des
années de prévenir et de ce métrage où
l'on est en mode réaction
ce qui fait qu'on se retrouve à faire
soit bouillir de l'eau ou simplement on
doit sortir et acheter l'eau ouais ouais
c'est ça avec des coûts faramineux
j'imagine aussi des bouteilles en
plastique ce qui na est pas du tout cet
environnement parce que les questions
environnementales ou s'ils sont très
très très important je pense qu'on monte
nordiques me disais que ne sonne ne font
pas mais en même temps on sait que le
pergélisol est bien assez par le
réchauffement climatique avec toutes
sortes de problèmes qui vont empirer
alors on a vu les évêques sortir ce qui
est annonciateur sans doute de l'arrivée
imminente du pape
on l'attend comme je vous le disais et
il est censé monter sur la scène je ne
sais pas s'il va assister au spectacle
si on a épuisé toutes les tous les
numéros qui était prévu mais ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'il va par contre prononcer
un discours
à lundi je pense que vous et moi on a eu
accès à ce discours on peut pas en
dévoiler la teneur mais on sait que ce
sera
un discours d'espoir tout cas ce matin
j'étais assis à côté de chorales si oui
et c'était assez comique parce que
mandanne et je lui ai demandé
ce qui peut faire autrement que par les
deux parties est ce qui peut revenir
autrement sur ces choses là et qu'on
réduit wii qui fait partie des positif
dans le sens vraiment très positif est
content maintenant payer les enfonce on
a besoin d'alliés c'est le cercle quic
en bref quatre discours au corps à sion
il est très positif
il dévoile un nom ne peut pas passer à
côté des pardons là en fait on devrait
changer notre vocabulaire soit dit en
passant c'est pas des pardons notre on
parle de ce sont des excuses de pardon
viendra de ceux qui ont été des victimes
paul inverse et on n'en est pas là nora
si on veut parler de
excuses auraient dit oui disait non
notre choix le pape n'a pas le choix
faut qu'ils reviennent là-dessus et
c'est vous imaginez si dit pas un mot de
sa n'arrive nagrand naour aussi qu'il ya
des problèmes on peut nommer des cas
peut donner des noms on peut donner des
années et que ce mode d adresse alors ce
serait comme quelle gaffe ce serait pour
lui de ne même pas faire allusion à
cette chose alors puis jeu j'essaie
souvent mais c'est vraiment tout ça
incluant et kalou et c'est dans cette
idée là deux rencontres d'expérience
physique avec des gens qui ont été des
victimes et il est assez il est assez
remarquable de voir ce que ce soit
aujourd'hui que ce soit hier il revient
systématiquement ce pape puis je sais
pas de prendre sa défense avait pas
besoin de mots pour sa défense mais il
est assez remarquable de voir depuis le
mois de mars qu'il fait c'est-à-dire
qu'ils essaient de prendre des éléments
de la culture autochtone de différents
éléments de la culture quatre îles de
l'est situé au même chapitre que s'ils
parlaient de frédéric lenoir ne fait pas
de gare marins ou de n'importe quel
philosophe autrement dit avec un respect
et une dignité à l'endroit des gestes de
la culture des langues et des idées ça
je trouve que déjà ce qu'on est déjà un
peu ailleurs que de queue de diable quel
drame viendra bientôt j'ai dit on le
sait
pour sal mais il ya aussi si vous voulez
parler d'espoir que madonna commence à
dire quelque chose pas seulement de
jovial islah mais quelque chose qui va
permettre de dire pas quelque chose que
cela je veux raconter une petite
anecdote parce que je vois qu'on attend
toujours les oui
je me suis amusé donc à regarder les
reportages de mes collègues de 1987 à
fort simpson alors là c'est hallucinant
parce que mes deux collègues nous
raconte des histoires absolument
phénoménale aging banda qui nous dit
enfin l'église reconnaît la spiritualité
autochtone jean paul ii est là il est là
pour quatre heures seulement l'avion se
pose débat qu il pleuve pas beau le
soleil apparaît et james est un poète
dans l'âme comme collègue de
journalistes il y dit enfin l'église va
reconnaît la spiritualité autochtone et
il dit même qu'elle le tambour dinars a
été entendu maintenant comme musique
sacrée comme si à 87 nous avions résolu
le problème vient de plus on a reconnu
la la culture la musique les moeurs on
reconnaît tout dépend de la nation
c'est de bon coeur c'était vraiment un
portage forme d'abord oui je sais d'où
il pourra compter pour vraiment vraiment
quelqu'un on a on en a pas eu d'autre
comme ça mais même chose pour louis
lemieux qui nous dit on et sur leur
terre il ya quelqu'un qui dit on est sur
leurs terres là on est lol et c'est
tellement significatif ça va passer à
l'histoire mais il manquait un drame mc
ya quelque chose de tellement gros c'est
comme un éléphant dans un salon qu'on
n'a pas vu et puis je pense pas que je
pensais personnes et une mauvaise
personne mais on as donc ce pape qui
pour la première fois de l'histoire
arrive aussi loin d'un art et on pense
qu'on n'a pas sa simple présence aux
horizons lui les problèmes alors
regardez aujourd'hui parallèle avec
françois et non pas avec j'ai besoin
d'elle que j'adore mais je fais parler
avec françois il est venu d'été ont eu
bob demandé de venir il est venu ici de
faire son pèlerinage potentiel et on a
vu que c'était sérieux et qu'on constate
vous moi et tout le monde et michel on
constate que le cheminement white n'ont
pas l'autre là c'est 87 s'il ya 35 ans
ça mais maintenant je veux na waie
traître alors oui alors michèle audette
justement en parlant ce cheminement donc
c'est tu c'est une étape qui a été
franchie avec avec la venue du pape
françois
une étape qui était incontournable
quel effet laurent on verra mais mais
c'était nécessaire c'est pas suffisant
mais c'était nécessaire
oui c'était nécessaire c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs demandé par des milliers de
survivants le qui ont osé ou qui ont été
courageux de partager leur vérité
pendant la commission vérité
réconciliation mais c'est aussi celui
celle qui croit pas du tout à ça c'est
le jeu je vais recevoir des messages
dans mes samedis ou des textos des
affaires de connaissances d'amis en
territoire a tiqué mais qu'un territoire
innu ou celle écrite qui vont
m'expliquer où
partager qui vont faire leur propre
expérience dans leur territoire et leur
procès alors on voit le pape applaudi
enfin il est apparu sans la scène
alors on voit des gens de toutes
origines improbablement des africains
j'ai vu qu'il y avait quand même dans
cette région très éloignée et très
nordiques que cette région attirer des
gens d'autres pays j'ai vu en trop qui
avait une population philippine ayons
pas 5 6% nos gens qui viennent d'autres
continents et qui habite à temps plein
haykel mythes qui ont fait leur vie
le par françois qui a toujours un petit
bonbon allez on remarque avancé avant ce
discours est là sur l'air de marcher une
tu sais quelque chose pour s'hydrater et
charles de batz été car vous aurez son
âge j'aurais dit bomboko janvier good
pour la sécheresse des yeux bien avant
ce qui l'emmène à good wife
[Applaudissements]
tomassi a ri si l'on assiste à tous ma
super ex est bien
là je
profitons de ce moment ensemble ou bien
sera t il au dalo
j'aimerais également donné la bienvenue
[Musique]
le groupe élite est un groupe de
chanteurs et de danseurs de cambridge
bay cela fait déjà 60 ans qu'ils
consacrent leur vie à leur découverte de
même
je voulais présenter
partie
high art berry a noté nick hamm aloïs
l'oit à quoi tout ça on aime ou mairie
et une à
l'afrique et le sourire par son bloc
marié le dernier est vivante qui a
déménagé ou lac et la dai et l'a
d'ailleurs le dernier chanteur en fait
vivent de l'autre la coque arrière vers
toulon
et mal aux côtes et critique
pour nous
car
nous avons ici des gens avec de nombreux
talents qui font du chant de gorge quand
il était jeune je crois que vous avez
peut-être six ou huit ans quand ils ont
appris
à chanter c'est leur grand mère marie
qui leur a appris
oui j'aime entendre la voix c'est un
événement qui est une chanteuse
classique du nunatsiavut
elle a chanté
ses marques déco des soucis une chance à
champ il noté tout de paix qu'on chante
traditionnellement à la période de noël
et au nouvel an
ensuite après dix ans à
venir
nous allons également entendre quitte à
perdre après
pitard va jouer le tombeau avec malaga à
mona lee qu
ils vont jouer pour
françois
nous allons maintenant écouter au le
côté le message du parrain suite
après les remarques du pape france 3
nous aurons la joie d'entendre le choeur
de l'église catholique notre dame de
l'assomption je vous propose maintenant
de donner la bienvenue à tout le monde
et de commencer
[Musique]
bonjour
vous avez devant vous des personnes
résiliente qui ont survécu mais qui ont
su également s'épanouir et c'est ce qui
est le plus important
vous tous ici présents
chez vous également
vous nous avez aidés quand on arrivait à
ce jour
les gens qui sont également venus avant
nous qui ne sont plus ici sont présents
dans nos coeurs
noms anciens pourraient être nos aînés
nous nos décédées seront également
présents avec nous aujourd'hui je
voudrais vous présenter aujourd'hui ma
famille car nous sommes toujours ici
ensemble en tant que famille
il y à une matra
et il ya eu lieu trichet il ya également
ici un danseur danseurs du tambour tamil
également qu' mac est une personne
importante et puis ma petite fille maïka
et noah
et mes autres
musiciens qui nous accompagne depuis
toujours
et ensemble nous allons chanter pour
vous
[Musique]
hélas
ja
et
comme ghana
[Applaudissements]
et il
m
aia
il y a
[Musique]
mohammad yahya
ja
et
rihanna
[Applaudissements]
biya
et mener ma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cela
ja
[Musique]
il y a
yahia
les
[Musique]
non
et on l'a fait
[Musique]
et à
ja
il y a
ce mode à
[Musique]
yahia
m
[Musique]
là adp
est l'homonyme à
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aie
il y a
il
[Musique]
y a
il ay ay ay ay ay à guilo l'ailé
loana
nommé l'été
[Musique]
e
aie
aie aie aie
[Musique]
il ya
là
ep
[Musique]
monique f
solana
il ya
[Musique]
il y a
comment
[Musique]
yahia
et à
y aller
ailleurs
diario
meillonnas au mollet
[Musique]
et ceux-là
hélas
il y a
sonam die
[Musique]
il y a
le montana
et un ep
tous nos monuments
et cela
aïe aïe aïe
aie aie aie aie aie aie aie
aie il y
aller
le nord
loana
[Musique]
la
ja
il y a
solana
[Applaudissements]
hélas
il n'y a
rêver
étonnant
[Musique]
hélas
soraya
ja
il y
avait la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
queue
la ion
[Applaudissements]
m
yahia
[Musique]
aie aie aie aie aie aie
et
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez le match
aller yuma
à lille où ma
ale human
alliot marie est sale et la roma allait
le maroc salalah oman alléluia alléluia
alléluia
allez demain à lille où mahmoud khalil
ahmad al yawm ahmad al hilal al youm al
ahly l'uma à l'hélium à al yom ha
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais
ne
vous
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vos petites minorités
souffrent ou sont
victimes
aujourd'hui
ça et moi dira petits
[Musique]
fournisseurs
étaient
semble-t-il à
s'en éloigner la
[Musique]
mythique
tous
apathie
tamini
voûte
inouïe
il
[Musique]
est
fini
au lit
août
[Musique]
temps maussade
ah oui oui tout ça
[Musique]
ça prenait
il
ouvre à sa
[Musique]
victoire à tout
comment
j'ai
[Musique]
tout senti
niort tout ça
qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ja
hey
ya
et à
et ea
aie aie aie aie aie
et
aie aie aie
[Musique]
il y a et à
et
à
il y a il y a
et
moi
ninon
maracana
aie aie aie aie
et
il y a
mais chariot et l'eau ces cas mario est
là
et on met
or ce
péno
maracana
aïe
aïe aïe aïe
et il
ia
apx
égalera are you are you call
et narbonne soit
elena la
ccip
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aie aie aie aie
aie
il y a
et
et au
[Musique]
noma
là
aie aie aie aie
il y a
et il y a
et
au yoyo est là et elle
rio est là
et au
mollet ce qu'est
marc ona
aie aie aie aie aie aie
il
ayez il y a
aulas
non
ok
ne savent pas qui aurait laissé percer
son épée
[Musique]
et
alors
oui le mec royal de manacor mec merci
merci énormément
à
l'époque nous pensions quand nous étions
heureux
attention avec joie
aujourd'hui nous sommes heureux
nous sommes contents de la visite du
pape
de quoi marquer
les anciens vous êtes contenu
du tambour le caribou
aussi le tambour avec lui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui notre culture
nous revient
nous révisons nos langues
c'est un moment de bonne à
l'époque de bonheur
bienvenue sur le territoire
inuit
sur le territoire qui est longtemps
pour que je viens d'utiliser
et bien nous nous en servons lorsque
nous sommes heureux lorsque nous dansons
avec joie aujourd'hui je suis heureux
je vous remercie énormément
de votre venue ici et au nom de tous les
uniques ici présent
je vais remettre montant bourreau pas en
notre nom à tous et à toutes
[Musique]
merci énormément d'être venu ici sur le
territoire nous et nous sommes vraiment
très heureux que vous soyez jeune ou
nous rencontrer ici merci énormément
merci je remet maintenant se trouvent
une méthode depuis le territoire
ils étaient toutes là je le remets à
saissac
ici nous rendre visite afin que son
rappel d'être venu ici quand il sera de
retour au vatican merci énormément
alors brièvement je te dire que cet
homme qui s'appelle le pit haïr n'est
qu'à 75 ans est un survivant de
pensionnat dans lequel il a passé onze
ans il s'est entretenu avec le pape tout
à l'heure il semblait manifestement
heureux il a dit si le tambour du
bonheur qu'il a offert au pape il était
heureux de sa rencontre il s'était rendu
au vatican en 2009 il faisait partie de
la délégation avec phil fontaine seul
film fantasia ce moment là avait pu
rencontrer le pape lui avait dû s'en
passer
et je crois que là on peut parler de sa
satisfaction
gadio c'est manon semaine où nous ça
court
chers frères et soeurs ou non sa cote
[Musique]
g salue cordialement la gouverneure
générale et je vous salue tous je suis
heureux de vous rendre visite je vous
remercie vos paroles vos chants de
danses votre musique
j'ai vraiment apprécié
le sens d'un single russian john drake
les
mathématiques la coupe
et les arrivages de janeiro amaro ils
ont menacé tout petit gars se trouvait
sur trois moniteurs et ça à moi je
retourne à cieutat obama ignoto mon moto
tourne à saint-herblain
c'est pourquoi nous travaillons
récemment
j'ai entendu plusieurs d'entre vous qui
ont été élèves dans les pensionnats pour
autochtones au lieu d'ouvrir la valencia
si je les remercie d'avoir le courage et
souffre lui de parler de partager des
souffrances immenses que je n'aurais
jamais pu imaginer que shaw avait émis
lundi à faire vivre en moi l'invasion et
puis la honte de ma compagne de mai qui
m'accompagne depuis des mois de mai 2010
ici encore
aujourd'hui encore je peux vous le dire
holman je suis affligé et je veux
demander pardon pour le mal commis par
de nombreux catholiques dans ces écoles
qui ont contribué à des politiques
assimilation culturelle une collation et
d'affranchissement
niveau ioana maintain me revient à
l'esprit le témoignage qui lui un ancien
un aîné qui parlait du bo de la beauté
du climat qu'il y avait dans les
familles
dans les familles autochtones avant le
système des pensionnats
cette époque où les parents les grands
parents les enfants étaient ensemble les
le comparer avec le printemps où les
petits oiseaux chantent heureux autour
de leur maire
il m'a dit que tout d'un coup les champs
se sont tus les familles ont été
démembrés on a arraché les enfants de
leur environnement et l'hiver est tombé
sur toutes les choses
et
on your enemy
d'inaction engine drive
in the
high
end pour faire un
discours
très
[Musique]
forte
hausse des
prix
fait - the broken à
andrew wang ou tekken wii music and far
away from home with two
lovers est visé
manama tout ça petit alors à ma monika
rühl homa est linéaire à 80 années qui
arrivent à capter quoi on est carrère 30
août hamara axeront leurs actes
européenne il ya le petit
canal au carrousel à oman où valny sur
mars mais nenê gameiro coûts dénommé
glow carcassonne aude pays cathare ni
hollow mélo tavannes et au quartier
m'embrasser sujet ma mère ni
au karting vassy et se marie en intérim
à vau-l'eau
tama quoi pinon l'umih alors toute
sa dynamique c'est rare déjà connue ilan
et aqua pineau revenir au matin à
majorer les concessionnaires
puis un haka romer détenus et les
narines et elina wiik tigo
apprécié alors sommes nous donc à monika
rühl au matin sur manigod
terminé sa muse et le goupillon youtube
il a guy moo-hyun quand il n'attire t il
une erreur d'amateur à quartino guy test
mené à mao romeo l'octo takkul logo
améliorera rio victorious niño courrier
yohanan thériault ude que temarii l'eau
katina terre a trait aux motards au
ghana mais
t'as quoi la coupe à noël ou pas le
radiateur ah nan men ou
qu'ils aient annulé
thanh haï no tokony car joli coup pas
noël à la rockhal raillard on ira au
matin il avait moo-hyun saura
théologique mais kyudo à l'audio logique
à me ramener ou qui ont mal l'eau
qui serait ma nuque la rejeter
comme si mal mais nous a dit
encore si elle met en regard avec la
parole de dieu
et son commandement du nord du père et
ta mère afin d'avoir une longueur sur la
terre que le seigneur
famille est un enfant est possible bien
de fallu non pas une telle poussée l'eau
si ce n'est pas
elle qui fait appareiller du moment les
enfants et séparés de leurs parents et
leur propre nation leur a été présentée
comme dangereuse étrangères
la civilisation forcé me rappelle un
autre passage biblique double récit
juste
qu'ils voulaient pas céder sa dignité de
ses pairs à ce gouvernant qui était prêt
pour la lui prendre
je pense aussi à ces mots forts que
jésus
continue quiconque outrage les tubes et
en maîtrise ou un serait ce pas là une
course blaise temps quand on brise les
liens entre par une deux avec ton mac à
vivre quand on porte atteinte aux liens
affectifs les précieux quand on fait du
mal qu'on laisse les
lionceaux crise que nos
morceaux
car elle est comme elle
est
vraiment
à force for work is about us ou skydrive
old spice ivan one to one
ivory
coast
swing scandola
comme candidat unique allait tout ça le
met à l'honneur une animalerie
nomicos après tin man amaro taqwa
trouvait un petit goûter au chaos signé
4 hier et ce maillot ni l'eau à tata
nano n'est qu'à matière toute sortie
inaugurale au sénat mi gothique tunis et
maya nani
cana il à ninon à tokyo narita et
malines il a game you would put à carole
mentionné picard mais aussi dans l'outil
année a par ailleurs été mariée
à malo tamana cap et anatole sonné à
lier la fumée le
tacot une autre série need a mené le
costa rica ou volés à l'hôtel où guy
parent continue car il ya aussi mining
mattana et nous travaillons diab nabot
que nous ayons maxime animal va nous
servir mais
si vous riez n'ont pas été aussi maillot
le pays au nom de ta petite aoc mayulu
tamako à agla dit ceci ou au cas où car
c'est ma yan et thomas quaas euros c'est
sûr quotidien ou conan et guy
pieters a homologué
tamana pinetop ses comédiennes anna your
area mais quand on gagne on a mariné aux
pratiques étaient renommés qui n'en
n'ont pas la taille arabe domique on
aurait un armistice et marne et kpn
automated malgré la
crise s'amuse
dans mon sac et ses amis
avec la volonté de parcourir ensemble un
chemin de guérison et de
réconcilier avec le soutien du créateur
nous aidera à faire la lumière sur les
événements qui se sont produits à
proposer sur son île
parlons donc de vaincre aujourd'hui à
nouveau tout comme lors de votre
rencontre et à marseille où vit vous
avez allumé et
lampes
illumine les longues nuits médias les
fonds du ce n'est pas tout
elle produit aussi télé chaleur permet
ainsi des brûlures assiste à l'appui le
crawl et amis nos étés mais c'est
essentiellement simoneau débit va
demeure encore aujourd'hui je suis père
mais simple de vivre une vie lumineuse
ne seront pas faciles
avis ne sert pas est atteint
[Musique]
et que jamais alors que la lumière qui
resplendit que nul n'y
a ni au feeling et nous raconte son
riche dans
lequel rochette white and what happened
in movement and paste à solingen is now
to sin meeting at the end of march
you have l'aide de collègues nathalie
des collègues des voix et hamid wintour
nights
hauteur
de souhait et oasis
event très
volumineux
et prennent nos
champs et nos hamas venait pour twixt
english
il n ya qu à malibu a chaotic même pas
les animaux arrivent à la normale aussi
vous marque au lion mâle de bharati guy
gouttes à
écailles au 15 août à san haïti nous a
révélé à huracan une ironique à malo à
des capitals a tout gagné par les rues
tamana carte au calme à palerme go
marthe mais
kamanyola do they can écoliers mais
comme marseille oklahoman
thanatologie mario simard mal ou qui
coûta de mr amadou talonné à glaire
migration nommer ou l'institut ont
cotisé malone et
à marc madiot jim hageman
hollow mélo tard la collecte pour yuma
real au made in use it in la journée
colonie
d'anatot comme planes à manama aux noix
ou la moe qu'en moa glaunez thèmes et où
voter
nage les quotas
au maillot jaune et
à médiouna nitot
été mis à l'arrêt si j'ai sur la
possibilité d'être
innocent de l'inuit natar imaginales
déposée mais après notre homme est aussi
de représenter ses immenses
après en être les gardiens
régulation en générant moi je vais péter
brosens exemple le respect dizaine oui
nos ceintures de fraternité et engage le
médium bien et la protection de
l'environnement à une harmonie d'un tel
ou tel qu au niveau de l harmonie entre
la terre habitée de carry le soir de
bruxelles elle est forte ils répondent
des 'commodities' liantes il répond avec
une éclatante lumière à l'obscurité qui
l'enveloppent
sert aussi comme j'attendrai comme
chantait pas fragile kouider il faut
comprendre en prendre soin danse mettre
à mal le flot voilà la tâche singulière
qui un confort
par exemple des meilleurs polars être
gardien de la trempe
de l'histoire hybrid faut
nous en garde à
vue et
mémoriaux
robot du raf kantorow dispose je
respecte ces riches
un répit pour il s'offrira
anhistorique un four
kerry
teaching and roll is the key to death tu
as you grippaux in particulier ceux pour
new by them all there have been called
carrefour
[Musique]
pouvait
supporter
a man no nano
et sur mana ce retour à rome et cathy ma
fatigue il a aussi le cas
tamana le mali a cité manakara
à l'eau
il à ninon et se marier au cape town en
actions miga zanoni
qui s'est ain et à man à la navigation
et will go pinarellu go
à mary pierce est égal à 4 go
ravis et man ray yasi qui nous va
assainir payet maroc dit pas les lycées
où
il ne te ramener l'eau experis it est
aussi
amaro à vaticiner qu'à ma tête aussi
taman appui aux arrêts au mali
le mas et l'île aux pies l'oaca ne
réussit
qu'à manaus à new york à c reuters
un mélo
à mes valeurs comme évaluation l'eau
netanyhou mi
avril aux années tu avais la cataracte
et logos
tamare nano n'a plus rien en attaque au
logo lycées titres
des métaux ni canard toulonnais et piggy
hôtellerie
et piloter à nord est c'est une marilyn
et à tin tam art na in où ils ne
retournent sur nos pilotes au mit et
caillau sortie le 8 avril et notre âme
nous inhalons
a dit tana le nadja
kamer été reçus il nous conte ici l'eau
amaro à torcé maria celli
qu'il n'a
jamais nous plutôt toi qui l'avenir de
cette terre présence de ce nom te dire
regardons les mots du capot est ce que
tu es de super
reconquiert loin tu vis vraiment les
possédés et
il faut séduire à nouveau ce que l'on
avait surnommé s'écoute en route mais
pas peur cédric mallaurie encore l'écho
celle des éoliennes de cieszyn toute
l'histoire à part le maire de novara
gestion de t'enflammer de prendre
position a souffert face aux gens ils
paraissent
et pour télé à faire resplendir la
langue c'est une existence
je voudrais te donner comme un frère
comme un aîné 3 la hauteur as you help
you
just
[Musique]
before he can become
et le nom
du navire freedom
trail surpasser norauto règne ou pick up
to be h
tél
shine bright eyes to another brodeur
would like the way you tripy savard vice
insu comme a continué radio maroc passé
simonyi que ça
t'amène à luna amar lomé
cacao car ces maillots
aux cadis yuma si tu te rates à ce
maillot me
à kanepi tard et la hauteur
plus tard est une arnaque naviaux high
roller le tpir marcilloux kg pierre ami
gary
et tout s'est régalé au cap et à sonnac
narines arrêt
à marotta center a tant lutté et ne te
rend le
takara tomy qt est élevé
à tournai racineux tarn et cetera par
les arrêtés
explique jeter à l'eau des piles l'on
règle ou ses
amarres au sérieux rnic
pilori le sait nicolas attendre ses
détracteurs actes arrêtés
écaillon l'eau c'est à quoi à oman et il
nous ici nous la fria technologie
canaris ne te pardonner
pinhas ionique aucun succès travaux et
cailloux tidjani
prix mélodies leur concert hausse camino
à ses conseils marylise lévesque
lyonnais de leurs dividendes aux
actionnaires at elle dit la fia ne te
rappelles tu a vocation à prendre de
l'âge 0-100 km/uh parce
qu'il vaut mieux penser
et consacra le trouble sur les hoax
physiquement apte à divertir et
dépasserait pas les vivants mamie tu
n'es pas fait pour ça la nouveauté c'est
toujours en équilibre entre devoir et
plaisir non tu fais pour prendre ton
envol vers les désirs les plus sincères
les plus beaux que tu à brive dans ton
coeur vers dieu pour les mets verton
prochain pour le service ne crois pas
que les grands rêves de la vie sont des
cieux inaccessible non tu es fait pour
prendre ton envol pour faire bien le
courage de la vérité défendre la beauté
de la justice pour élever ton
tempérament morale être con pas s'en
servir les autres et construire des
relations oui pour semer la paix et
l'attention aux autres où que tu ailles
pour être l'étincelle pour l'
enthousiasme de ceux qui t'entourent
pour aller plus loin nos tours niveler
est au
plus
bas
[Musique]
et user
et niort miss
france
mais
elle bute
sur marca
interview neil
jenkins
arras à noter le beau
nom you may cry
triste car geof truth and viewing chasse
ce two lovers mort au temple biblique on
passe tous ses revendeurs un trou béant
richesse
aussi sophie sono wenger wherever you
are the night in tunisia ce moment au
dos or on joue tous qui précisons-le est
naturelle et running out
si vous ne pas pratiquer ces cailloux
ticks à rieumes oreilles aptana cailloux
sigui par mas palégry
tamale occultation mieux carlos et
cailloux si vite et puis le soir ne
réussit pas à wasquehal mais avoue marc
khanne les picasso arrêté
amarok attaque sao paulo à rossinot
canal jean louis
il mais vous percevez arar avait éliminé
tous milito
ac adriano mais tu n'as westerlo
que ces années
il caille au torino met à mal aux nôtres
hélas il n'y est une arme et il y en a
ça gâte une nappe toxo ruine menace et
qui sait aller mac et apollo ses pyjamas
amazon vous goûtez
nagle gilgo saleh rya selo
tamako et nous on met synac thurman et
qui tuent et pillent on pille axa uni
gagner est maintenant il le sait sur
l'eau oui nous happe tout était très
calme et qui s'est renié expiré ce t
elle le sait assez cynique payer de se
relancer et nous rattrape terre l'eau
c'est inouï opère une marotte ammann n'a
à ma carnation et le ckps celui toujours
sénat glynn écolo c'est à mario tama
nakama galgo
si pour moi goûter à canards logos evo9
ça si vous connaissez ma la cité royale
au
vélo mais par dessus mais vous pourriez
grassi c'est bien que tu reconnais
toujours à l'affût il y à cette force de
gravité de l'esprit qui nous retient
nous tire vers le bas classe nos désirs
pour affaiblir votre joie
dans ces moments là
à la sterne arctique hirondelles de
l'argent qui logent chez nous on
l'appelle
elle elle ne permet jamais que les vents
contraires et variations de température
l'empêchent de parcourir l'ensemble du
territoire que nous sommes direct
parfois à lantin bien ce chemin détourné
et l'accès de deux dvi et plus elle se
laisse fléchir par les courriers plaît
mais elle sait à ce jour où est son
temps et elle
rencontrera des gens qui voudront
démolir des rêves celle où tu te
convaincre de toutes les sphères de peu
ou des taux d intérêts personnels et
ngoc et voilà qui demandera pourquoi
m'appliquer à faire cela les autres nous
avons là le nom et puis comment puis-je
volé dans un monde qui semble toujours
tomber des scandales des guerres les
tromperies d un justin disponible de la
destruction de l'environnement de la
différence s'avèrent les plus faibles
les comportements décevants de la part
de gens qui devraient monter réglages
poète face à ces interrogations
se
font
jour
keep it clean ce
week-end à chara et des
attentes et chose entraîneur bruce
excepte dit tu adaptes selon
andy
lipow
here
we go my way
the world from justice in for men
traction indoor france tout
ce
qui se rapporte aux cataractes au sénat
aura aussi un serial aïe on earth hour
and time and in matin qui ces années les
hayot martil légaux
ou opérer ou non mais tu t'en es tu n'es
plus tard mais mal à homards et a passé
mais qui sait année quatre acteurs
nationaux seront effacés l'acteur a
marre opiomane raya route nous
interrogations le thé
à marco werner
et à la sociologie
tamedia
copa noir
span style
dans la copa noir tarzana thoracique
tommy
hamaoka ouvertement packs d'eau mam a
parlé at-il logo à connacht qu'aux alors
jack aussi la norme colo
qui sert niculae rien n est acquis ma
tournure quand vous maquillez aussi une
asso d'envoi take on m'arrête à ramer
à malo
il est nul après tu n'as retour du
cannet mal tu es mal l'intérêt au pérou
opérations de raffinage aux valeurs
n'est pas noir ou gris tma-14 marama le
large mais tu es mon imac attaque
certains n'en sera peut-être le cas
makoun ou happy with you know a contacté
rayonnante se retirer leurs lots à
maraval et eni puis une intervention est
lyonnais
tamako à
thomas d'ajouter louis hanot étaient
mêlées
où tout exacte a acheté un appartement
qu avec os x et sarah tartine oui alors
les couilles en or pas
tu sais faire des a dit corinne
j'aimerais te dire à toi j'ai un tir
manuellement cros et une frère ce retour
du jeune tous actuellement nous sommes
pour le comité rennais jamais existé
alors que si tu as quelqu'un de normal
mais
l'accalmie je
les ai dit
tu peux apporter
non tout cela et se retrouveront demain
car chacun de nous est unique il mondo
caritas et erich et jon k cette
vérité-là richard dont tu as raconté à
ma mère qui concerne la paix y aller il
affirme ils ont viré jouait les poussent
vers mario un vieux thann pour le calcul
de survie pour toi tout ce qui exigerait
le pays ne s'est jamais d'autorisation
mer un seul instant il crée total elle
croit qu avec leurs lots de consolation
est un moment déjà mal un crumble que le
futur gardois et surtout quand tu lèvera
les choses là claude naud tenir la corde
et je suis locataire la maison
donc
à la
victoire si la météo ne leur dit jamais
que je m'attends pas à pas vers le
meilleur talent est là
moldavie passion avéré l'auteur visé se
mettre
au travail
en pivot
géorgien
you my brother and your mind the
guardian
note chez pika once you give a dû à
paris orly
because there is even know in your
hands
in which we
are in your hands because it choix navas
et unique
européenne
à venir te
events comme google view white and free
choice of jour écrire or distributed by
you
guys narcisse
racaille francine yu na force sa quête
qui brille seigneur tu ans
when you s'y tiennent you can't live
without
you
you can't
see
you in brief sociaux entrust
des cas si mourinho yves nat hostens
were used à brive et ignorent sauf
sow né rousseau
find guy verreault guerre du nord est
new na bisso we go for a new johnny deux
pays tous deux ps
sept gps du wild en or gris destiné à
tous
il m'a d'ailleurs pas c'est qu'ils y
trouvent aussi tu avant l'arrêt au celi
s'appelait la piscine et au sahara ces
manips si nous que nous et tous qui ces
années ci vous knicks a du goût mais
arras et
luna régnier devancé marc assez aventis
il ôta marne à
nurieux notre antihéros yuna made in our
atterri à celle ô allah après l'homme
ne réunit retard
ne rien à ramon
qui nouveau vaccin et tout mais tous ne
procède à nommer
tama quoi tigres mais arras ou au pénal
et ils ont menacé à jean et une angoisse
et addington awarta tamana le lord
jouineau viguier out
soon as you take my hoarau marque buell
haut nil où il imite sérieux ces
maillots
un bar aux
opérateurs loïc puyo narnia ses piques
canaria six
succès à ramasser l'eau
tapas web et la 14e avec alternèrent de
série l'allemande très versatile de ses
pilotes au mit
à saint-denis niall tarn a dit ceci et
l'inédit courteille d'un animal qui
s'aiment les christina o télé aurait été
à tort qu'elle ait heurté à ce rouleau
les éliminer il est né le au
perreux-sur-marne puis lors de mes ml
opérationnel il a amassé
n'est rien mais à ses yeux étaient les
terres ces cailloux s'intéresser aux
maternités à malo
aogo adjani tous ces thèmes à kye-ossi
l'uci si vous m'invitez à l'opposé il
narre le cpe n'a pas molli ne sera pas
aussi tard la route à mort et écoutaient
afrique du sud il nous dessiner
thapan accueille aussi quitté
le secondaire ainsi qu il a la luz elle
a vraiment été scellée qu'en solo
personnel colis que tous nous massacrer
par ati quoi elle existe est pareille à
celle allouera darija nous sur le viêt
on assimile aux contrats défendre les
petits sinon qu arabia quotidienne à
manta jamais de chez valentin loblaw
evrard monde lalouette au sort aura des
touristes à delvin quel touriste ou
l'autre tout prêt à porter notre projet
apporte à l'autre
il apparaît assez loose et qu'ils savent
qu'à la vie à cahors corrida
si ayew la lucha quotidien al andalus et
la lumière qui nous succédera faut hélas
une nouvelle marque et la sino d'un
cloud en hausse el camino de la loose
rykiel et valiant décision de corazones
contre la corrida de la face à alès
récupéré de sa range à louer nikos tombe
face à l'obscurité des mentions je
l'appellerai venir écrit ce que l'on
fait et choisit la rage au coeur que les
lambris développer de bonnes habitudes
faut bien vivre à ne pas poursuivre des
traînées lumineuses éphémère des feux
d'artifice qui ne laisse que de la fumée
ce sont des illusions des parodies de
bonheur comme le disent et ici au canada
jean paul ii il n'est sans doute pas de
ténèbres plus épaisse que celle qui
silice dans l'âme des jeunes lorsque
defour prophète éteignent temps de la
lumière de la foi et de l'espérance et
de l'amour mon frère ma soeur jésus est
proche de toi et tu désires éliminait
ton corps pour te faire venir à la
lumière il a dit je suis la lumière du
monde mais il a dit aussi ac dc dont
vous êtes la lumière du monde toi aussi
ton que la lumière du monde et tu le
deviendra de plus en plus si tu quittes
pour éloigner de ton coeur la triste
obscur ceux du maïs aurait pas ici
white wings fayçal d'alcas 50 coulis
de pologne ou
evry des
[Musique]
émissions
jeudi
elie
co2 brown hauteur de
10% de tarnos et restriction qui pose
[Musique]
exchange on july le fait en europe est
moche et nos vies quotidiennes
brothers
sisters jesus is love to you and i want
to live and
thank you come to go loyers qui sert au
crime sauf ayem told the world
you are all right of the world
youtube n 1 but à 0 et new line up
brahimi et few chaude aux castors de
dark shadows ovivo première at
elle pensé que ça ferait sans doute
tenir aux mayas et yattara à mon mari
noma ce jeu vous vite qu'à taxer marc
ayrault vélo
tracteur logo i ly nous réussit quand
même à
hama amadou moctar avatar comme un tract
orientation l'otage ou
inouïe nounoune et pertinents nitot qui
sert notamment comme auxerre tararata
à oman au mélo
takuya au tir marx et le natural mod est
ici trop mal mais c'est à mario à nara
vous tienne
il vit il vit toile août à la tuna
quotidiennes assurées logo à manama le
nez ils nous ont emmenés par thomas
paiement soit raptor nouveau
et prometteur l'eau piolot angelina sous
ta ta valise après yannick noah parle
pas comme ça on est timide amélioration
mal à glace il obstiné
à manama cailloux si le sait
il est consulté un avocat
notaire ou dix années
tarn en tout cas mal
sur l'eau comme ohio
bouillon ne remercierons motards qui si
elle est à toi tu as raison du tournage
où
[Musique]
il ose toulon et nice argent métal nommé
pita charisme moment
d'anaheim a nommé à matignon
l'honneur est nommé à manly nommé
apte à noter qu'à regarder passer
d'ici cellino ghanem al ahmar aux
camaïeux malone et il vit en matinée
tallahassee maillot
new mario albert kamoni roma
à marilyn et à écouter mais nos parents
aimants minimale à oman et au beausset
illicite aux harmonies vous à manille où
vivent aussi une large mesure aux
maternités axerons axerons up par la
pearl go
on m'a dessiné
quelques difficultés pour apprendre
en recherchons continuellement des
solutions sepa la gallardo séparer
chaque jour la lumière des télés
allemandes auront
précisément ainsi en séparant
nous observons simplement la meilleure
scène il devance apprendre à distinguer
la lumière des ténèbres un peu sa
rencontre à noter que commencer on se
demande qu'est ce qui me semble brillant
élections de l'an passé qui me laisse
ensuite comment vous avez une intérieure
celle occasionnée mais a subi un frère
que ça c'est du vrai je laisse la peau
javi lópez m6 estelle moi que je sorte
d'abord du fait de la domination des
salles ou instinct mais voilà la fois et
je me demande quelle somme ils se
séparent à la force qui permet de se
servir de nous séparer en chasser une
ombre et lumière des ténèbres qui se
plaît à dire ni autorisation du métal et
bois occasion de bien et va très
certainement mais pas laisser la liberté
ce n'est pas ça
ce n'est pas ce que je dois faire malgré
les autres
totalement table et leurs ébats c'est
une responsabilité
et une plus grande et l'est nous a donné
en même temps que l'avis
de
tous
live from the
thing you
do
they know
i
never
ever meet again
vieillissent et au masters sur install
va in the light painting
and risk
and acting as a
free
world où il
tenait aussi à travers et vous aussi
canaan banana axerons martenet auront
maintenu glos
a prévu six années que nous attardons
nous
tamare n'a pas où tu as mal avec toyota
yaris obama nommé amnon miglos
le nord du ram et ku milk d'être l'hôte
à papa petit îlot cardio good goût d'été
marque figueras manimal carl monette
alors nos tartes au lot avec julie aux
vagues août à témara puis on arrive au
goutte à au maillot torlot
camara relevé
nathalie pignard en orbite a
ovationné après you not good kiss ou
thema si vous ne parvenez on va le
torpille mynhardt orlova
qui se tenait à vannes et sur l'entité
sioniste a pas il leur avenir dira
peut-être pas tarder à tamesloht n'y
aille pas ramollo qui se tait mappy ou
va à mario been internautes ou matinée
ses manoeuvres à petit et
tana si vous non pas à carla ni l'eau
n'est
pas au niveau
amaro après qu'un bois
qui souhaité m'appuyer mena
puis on en a ramené aura à vis à vis
ctive si on ne marque pas un maillon mes
cartons miglos illuminé ou va tenir à
carreau la petite fille à maromme amiral
marty se
taît ce morceau roland dumas et se
marrent seront en tout cas graves peau
il a admis que pillon à tour au
monitorat l'ordinaire à caractère ramiz
iseni
tamla et se marrent seront demain
à un sit-in tôt
il nous dit lohan et à l'appui non pas
au qatar à oman
poliment et aircelle consejo assez
l'équipe pour enfin le troisième volet
sagan des grosses amath wade les jeunes
font de grands efforts ensemble
merci parce que vous les jeunes vous
êtes comme les étoiles du ciel qui
supprime d'une manière ou merveilleux
leur beauté mais de l'ensemble des
constellations quelle forme et qui donne
la lumière est orienté nuit de sommeil
vous aussi appelé aux auteurs du ciel et
à veiller sur la terre vous êtes fait
pour vivre en ce sens il faut permettre
aux jeunes de flamanville d'être en
mouvement ne peut pas passer leurs
journées isolées prise en otage par un
téléphone les grands glaciers de
sénateurs ne faut penser au sport
national du canada le hockey sur glace
comme possible comment le canada
parvient-il à remporter toutes ses
médailles olympiques
en effet comment l'on fait ça rahner
marie fait les poulains la marque pour
marquer autant de buts
ok convaincu conjugaux c'est bien la
discipline et la créativité que la
tactique et le brésil c'est le seul l
esprit d équipe fait toujours la
différence
[Musique]
indispensable pour faire face aux
circonstances imprévisibles d'usure
faire équipe cela signifie croire que
pour atteindre de grands objectifs
l'objectif on ne peut pas inventer le
tout seul on doit bouger ensemble répond
avoir la patience de combiner dépasser
le mouvement afin de créer des
stratégies de jeu cela signifie
également laisser de la place aux autres
sorties rapidement quand c'est vers
tours et encourager vos idées ses
coéquipiers voici l'esprit décline les
deux seuls piece of my big love et i
know
you
youtube
et change 0,9 un maître-chien trigger in
your love
you lie boad bio malt kong et du bien de
move vers 15h10 au monde assure son
fonds de retraite les visuels
meeting à
[Musique]
la mairie swing au dos olympique mais
ronald turner remarie filet poulet
ghetto scorant roskosz
acquis quand by the spleen elle crie t
ry
tactics elle fait se construit bakhtine
spur au xv de france
existent et les i thank you for us
phoning je vis un peu des tiberi
avrillais
teamwork mise bolivie et north sea uk
n'a qu'un rôle du mouvement
3 team work of the making of a down
quick wins insulteur encino new team in
da estime ce pur
qui ont entamé l'aura du mal à y
arrivera à prix cassés
caterpillar catherine tamana makoun 4 jo
doit ramer attaché aux pratiques et aux
haras mai puis yannick pinaud matin
avant laquelle la route qui soutient la
révolte et il nous tous il le dit
mchugh tout aux lauréats nova c'est
l'horaire d'été aura ses imac adapté à
ma raquette à mal et nous n'avions ni
tamana i look to you tube pouliot à
l'onu ou l'oréal locative temmar
à 12h04 matin
il hésite à des mâles
omar était vide on arrive aussi
attention at il aussi marc couture
qu'at-il de ma carrière avoue matin il
n'y aura pas tant le big lots
into now derrière hamilton aura
auparavant le lot à activités matinales
ou t'es
tu as mal et nous la grille à signer
des gamins canada mais
il a tu as quoi à youtube
un
prêt il ya ka kanatami pingwa autre
adaptation n'est acquis me
anouar au canada mais canada mieux
pinoit avec doivent tout ou partie des
olympiques madonnina sommes ouverts à
nos ados dacquois physique car news
sérieuse aujourd'hui marie fait les
pôles square nakata si mauvais à kenner
tamana accès root aloni pili moxa au
tholonet quatre marques à majorité
maxi-catamaran locarno pyrobio norman a
dit me gillot après les absurdités and
it is art sous tipis captant motta qui
ces années à 4,04 tandis qu'à maroc at
il dit sous
thèmes aglukkaq l'osi il nous tous
menacés
at un petit cube in iraq atterri dans le
marais à cannes en
tenue zarno la haye honneur acteurs
novelli moxa à talonner t michael ortega
a talonné au loudes il animait à lyon
notamment
quatre activités à l'onu
14h04 guiterne ap la petite fille aurait
ramené où seront minimales à city ni à
mare-aux-vacoas vertueux ac vers le oui
amaro ricard ciara navette en a assez et
caillau sûr mais legault
tamana
ta perry newman
4,4 guillemin
à mios mais m aminé nationaux à marcher
vers le zinc à la vie assez à la lumière
chaque jour fait
cela dans votre propre folie sur les
noix quand cette belle langue inuktitut
août le bseo quelques uns écoutant les
personnes âgées les avions puissant dans
la richesse de vie traditionnel et de
votre liberté et leur route dans le
passé évangiles que vos ancêtres ont
gardé transit et de ventre et le visage
hideux de jésus-christ lorenzi on
courait vous bénis de tout coeur et je
vous dis pour hanami
ronald
king of pop country achetés nbi partie
[Musique]
des inouk face aux
interviews des
couilles en ami
[Applaudissements]
il ne pratique a cueilli au sujet des
personnes arrêtées
hamamura [ __ ] et à maroc attaque à
jos et
tama inouk au casino xi une petite heure
rapport logo et les cours si c'est à
doha tamgho
amarone rien à toutes ses attentes
naulleau
n'a atteint les inouk inorganiques
isnani
amaro et l'écossé nina tour puis aussi
signer tamako à toulouse amazon
allemagne et se marrent seront amenés à
temps mais l'eau
à marée haute à quoi gosses pelli à
civaux nice simone ici ni nassima
youtube aujourd'hui à marc o tac o jogo
hinault qui na na na na 10e c'est
à ça et marquer passer au mac est né à
maroeuil lissine neymar au coq poma
konami
[Applaudissements]
je ne paie pas de
c'est parfait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par
ailleurs alors ans est à l'alpha
notre travail et au super bowl bidart 64
compagne viennent j'aimerais volonté
soit faite sur la terre comme au ciel à
nos jours d'une autre point de ce jour
pardonne nous nos offenses je pars
donnons aussi à ceux qui nous ont
offensés et ne nous laisse pas entrer en
tentation mais délivre nous du rab
que l'on soit avec
vous mais il est le seigneur un peu ce
même jour que le nom du seigneur sont
avec vous même
nom du père du fils et du saint-esprit
alors voilà c'était le dernier discours
est probablement la dernière prière du
pape en sol canadien puisqu'il s'apprête
maintenant à prendre la route de
l'aéroport on entendu chaleureusement
applaudi par l'assistance qui est là
devant cette scène 10 cas 8 ou 9 août
alors on sait il est arrivé un cetain ce
genre très très court une visite de
trois heures à peine
mais qui a duré plus longtemps
finalement puisqu'il a longuement
entendu les survivants il raconté leur
histoire en privé
alors je vais te souhaite aller chercher
mais panélistes je vais les appeler
comme ça qu'ils ont écouté ce texte donc
alain je vais commencer par vous on a
entendu tous les discours les homélies
messe du pape jusqu'à maintenant encore
une fois il a demandé pardon mais je
dirais que c'était vraiment pas le quart
de son discours c'était plutôt un
message aux jeunes donc à l'avenir à la
jeunesse qui devrait bien mais ce qui
m'a dit il ya eu 9 9 2009 discours du
pape depuis qu'il est arrivé ici mais je
dirais que je suis restée accrochée au
début pourquoi parce que j'ai eu
l'impression que c'est le moment le plus
personnel que j'ai vu à venir jusqu'ici
dans ce voyage où il dit où il fait
allusion aux gens qu'il a rencontrés à
rome comme dc il dit samassa réveillant
mois les 10 nations et la honte et il
ajouté dit que je n'aurais jamais
imaginé déjà on est dans un autre faire
quelques règlements d il ya quelque
chose de terrible qui vous est arrivé il
dit quelque chose comme ça ensuite j'ai
vu j'ai remarqué que dans la traduction
il le fait allusion au mal mais un
anglais ça a été traduit par ivo on voit
que ya une gradation dans l'industrie
déjà visé le passage moi qui m'a
vraiment pas qui m'a plu mais qui je
trouvais été significatif c'est tout
tout début quand il est tout à coup le
champ s'est arrêté les familles ont été
désagréger les enfants emportés loin de
leur milieu l'hiver est descendu surtout
il ya déjà une belle plume là dedans
mais y ajoute la douleur suscite aussi
le scandale encore plus si on compare à
la parabole de duke il commanda honore
ton père et ta mère est là j'ai pas pu
faire autrement je vais vous dire
honnêtement parce que je me dis ah oui y
avait ça m'arrive quand même le mot je
peux vous lire la bible aujourd'hui mais
il y avait cinq ans même dans la bible
aimé mais qui c'est qui a pris les
enfants qui a brisé les liens entre les
parents les grands parents les enfants
et tout le reste qui au fait en sorte
qu' on a rompu la confiance et la mode
est un et des autres et surtout l'amour
de notre langue et de la culture c'est
l'église bien sûr vous allez me dire
c'est l'éleveur je sais je sais je sais
mais n'empêche que y est en train de
nous dire c'est terrible c'est terrible
c'est épouvantable ce cauchemar cette
histoire ben ouais mais alors nous on
s'est alors je trouvais que dans sept à
bullock qui est personnel soit avec un
langage très simple je trouvais que
c'est le plus proche on a été de francs
soit dans cette histoire avez vous
l'impression son passage que tout ce
qu'il a tous ces témoignages qu'il a
entendu pendant son passage au canada
ont transformé justement lui ont fait
comprendre encore plus profondément la
douleur vécue michel
je vous dirais les premières minutes je
laisse un petit très intime avec les
gens la façon le choix des mots est
évidemment il ne parlait encore de
certains individus mais l'introduction
et plus tard j'ai pu m'accrocher at
l'espoir quand j'ai entendu mais aussi
mon passage préféré
lorsqu'il fait référence au chant qui se
sont arrêtés à partir de là j'ai senti
que tous ces mots pouvaient s'appliquer
à l'ensemble de l'église à l'ensemble de
ce qui s'est passé depuis trop longtemps
dans les pensionnats dans les écoles de
jour dans les communautés qui ont eu des
missionnaires des prêts d'écurie qui ont
fait des acteurs je dirait criminel 7 me
suis accroché à quelque chose en faisant
même si 10 des individus le reste du
message bien enveloppé 12 heures
marie-eve coton donc on compte pas
devient comme ça formulé des excuses des
demandes de pardon c'est un pas mais
c'est un pas vers la guérison et ce
texte seul homme nous amène plus loin ou
pas là dedans je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose car comme moi qui me touche et
dans le texte je reprends un peu lorsque
ce qui a été dit mais quand il parlait
de j'ai honte depuis plusieurs mois soit
j'ai trouvé le mot très important de la
honte d'une part parce que les gens sont
sortis du pensionnat avec un sentiment
de honte l'impression d'être inférieure
c'est aussi ce que laisse comme
séquelles des abus sexuels en général
sont les victimes et là il reprenait la
honte de dire c'est pas à vous d'avoir
honte j'ai honte commun vous avez été
traité ça pour moi au niveau
psychologique j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant et j'ai trouvé intéressant
qui s'adresse à la jeunesse parce que
justement on est devant le peuple qui au
départ puis se suicide le plus au monde
c'est chez les jeunes que le tout se dit
le plus alarmant donc de parler de
lumière de parler de d'avenir de parler
de acquis les inuit le savent les gens
le savent peut-être pas la maison mais
aiment beaucoup leur qui joue à suivre
donc de s'adresser à la jeunesse je
pense que ça peut être bien aussi merci
beaucoup michel là c'est pas fini la
suite maintenant l'oeil la conférence
des évêques catholiques du canada qui
s'engagent lacan pu bien communiquer ce
soir et qui disent bon s'engage on a
entendu on va on va aider les survivants
à guérir de traumatisme on va continuer
on va divulguer les archives on va les
préserver les divulguer on s'engage à
qualifier les politiques de la doctrine
de la découverte bref toutes les demain
les artefacts toutes les demandes c'est
pas précisé pas l'engagement précis
c'est pas non plus il n'y a pas
d'échéancier mais bref on ont dit oui on
a entendu tout ça et oui on va faire des
gros efforts dans ce sens mais si vous
attendez vous coup encore c'est juste le
début leur de pour ma part le message
est clair maintenant tout le monde est
au courant du moins demain les gens vont
voir ce qui s'est passé et ça devienne
responsabilité collective et ceux et
celles qui ont envie d'avancer et moi je
suis là comme père et d'autres personnes
qui vont vouloir contribuer à cette
réelle réconciliation
alors voilà je vous remercie infiniment
tous les trois on a eu trop peu de temps
finalement pour parler de tout ça après
le discours du pape mon ait amplement de
parler du nunavut dont on parle trop
rapidement marie-eve coton merci
beaucoup michèle audette merci beaucoup
alain crevier merci beaucoup
voilà le pape est venu il a vu il a
écouté il a demandé pardon il a prononcé
des paroles que les premiers peuples
avait besoin d'entendre de la part du
chef de l'église catholique même s'il
n'a pas répondu à toutes leurs attentes
des mots qui ont leur souhaite les
aiderons maintenant acheminés vers la
guérison mais cette guérison et la
réconciliation nous appartiennent aussi
à nous c'est une responsabilité partagée
par toute la société nous avons fait de
notre mieux à travers ses émissions
spéciales pour y contribuer et je
remercie toute l'équipe qui est la
recherche à la réalisation et à la
production a travaillé avec coeur à
préparer ses émissions merci au revoir
[Musique]
m
wacom joe allen
je demande humblement pardon pour le mal
commis par de nombreux chrétiens contre
les peuples autochtones
[Applaudissements]